ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
welcome to another exciting episode of
shim cast IRL this is our second
official shimcast Tim wasn't doing so
well he's been struggling so we sent him
off to a farm where he's going to run
around with all of the other beanied
journalists all day long and he's gonna
have a great time so well you know Tim's
been getting a little older and he's not
able to skateboard as much as he liked
excuse me so as easily yes we just want
him to be around people who can help him
and take care of him yeah it was like a
like a farm where people take he's like
on a farm with other Farmers no he's on
a farm with other journalists and
they're all running around and having a
fun time wearing their are they writing
articles uh yeah absolutely yeah if they
want to they can but I think they're
having so much fun skateboarding oh yeah
and sometimes when you go to a fun Farm
yeah he may want to stay there for a
minute what longer than a week uh you
know I we just wanna
we don't want to promise anything right
now buddy knock what kind of farm
we'll we'll probably get into it in a
bit but he's okay he's he's having a
worry we don't want you to worry well
thanks yeah I'm worse of course well
don't ladies and gentlemen tonight's
Stories the Democrats are denouncing RFK
after the New York Post has accused him
of anti-Semitism gays against groomers
did a sting operation on Planned
Parenthood and the Community Health Care
Network it's a very interesting story
we're going to get into in a bit uh
Obama slams concerned parents who want
to ban pornographic material from
schools regurgitating the same banal
this is book Banning rhetoric we've been
hearing from everyone on the left a pro
pedophile group slams The Sound of
Freedom unsurprisingly that and many
other stories coming up tonight but
first I'd like to ask every single one
of you to smash that like button I want
you to smash that like button so hard
that our buddy Tim feels it from the
farm he's on right now all right really
make him proud and I'm also going to ask
you to go over to timcast.com to become
a member if you become a member you're
going to be able to watch the after show
and the after show is going to be
interesting it's going to be spicy it's
totally uncensored you'll also be
supporting the Empire that's being built
over here at timcast.com and of course
I'd also like to ask you to head over to
casbrew.com okay get yourself a bag of
coffee we're building culture we are our
own sponsor this allows us to do all of
the cool things that we want to do cool
things such as inviting our very special
guest Libby Evans onto the show Libby
how are you doing tonight I'm doing good
Sheamus thanks yeah good to be here yeah
happy to have you happy to have you we
are also joined by the one and only
Hannah Claire hi I'm Hannah Claire
brimlow I'm a writer for timcast.com I'm
excited to be here with Libby from post
millennial I think everyone knows that
you're a post-millennial millennial
human events very excited to be here and
I'm glad that our my fellow Colorado
Colorado Travelers is just there as in
Colorado Springs what's up Tim saw you
at the airport what's happening homie I
I'm hearing vibration through my headset
but you guys said you're not so if
everyone in the audience is not cool
otherwise I'm going to move seats yo I
just started my workout today so we did
I was in Colorado do this music video uh
I'm shot the well I don't wanna I don't
want to spoil it but basically I'm doing
a body transformation for them for the
music video and uh I was a hit the gym
hard and I'm doing protein I've got to
eat 2 800 calories a day now oh my God I
went for like a thousand calories I was
eating like a thousand a thousand I had
like an eight percent body maybe Bird
yeah what's wrong what's going on I just
sit I mean I'm just sit in slim silence
you know so this is new for me I've been
chugging protein shakes and eating
chicken for the for most of the day but
man it feels good once you get past that
that 20 minutes after that burn of your
bicep it's just like
you know you get back to back to basics
and then you let the let the calories do
the rest I suppose I'm glad to hear a
good shredded man I'm excited for the
music video yeah and I also have to my
right the man the myth the legend surge
pushing the buttons yes indeed trying to
get this working right thanks uh I'm
search.com hope you guys are well
all right so tonight's first story RFK
has been slammed is anti-Semitic for a
claim he made that there's a
conversation that needs to be had
surrounding some allegations that kovid
is more likely to in fact or is more
likely to result in mortality among
certain ethnic groups so we can watch
this video right now and then we'll talk
about what some of the people in The
Press are saying about him
oh actually do you think YouTube might
get mad at us if we play this whole
thing why
they're sensors no I don't think so yeah
all right we'll play it
you hearing that no I'm not getting any
audio all right well it's not coming
through the audio well we get that
working
um we're just gonna we could talk about
it yeah we're just gonna explain this so
basically
RFK said as I mentioned and he wasn't
even saying that he necessarily believed
that this was the case but he's saying
that there needs to be a conversation
surrounding the fact that according to
him certain studies are showing that
kova does seem to disproportionately
affect certain people and he was
claiming that the effect that it's
having on people is based on genetic
factors that are linked to ethnic or
racial background now I find it very
interesting that the left is losing
their minds about this because they were
actually saying very similar things
about kova during the pandemic yes this
was early on the CDC was saying that
covet had a greater impact on black and
brown communities right they were saying
this specifically they were saying too
that if you were not taking covert
precautions you were not only killing
grandmas but you were racist yeah
because you weren't paying enough
attention and I think it's interesting
because they also made this a
justification for allowing people of
color to take the vaccine first so this
was uh there were a whole lot of
affirmative action style policies
surrounding coved the implementation of
treatment all of these things and now
you're not allowed to say that well
exactly I mean they were constantly
claiming that the African-American
community in particularly the black
community was being disproportionately
affected by coven because of this we
needed to be sure that they got the
vaccines first and so RFK he's saying
something a bit different because he is
outwardly making the claim that this is
based on genetic predisposition he's not
necessarily cultural factors but I don't
even know if he's making that claim or
he's just saying that is a claim we have
to investigate exactly but what happens
when we listen to this and if you listen
to him talking he starts it off as
saying there's an argument that and then
he starts talking that this does this
and this does this and if you take it
out of context it sounds like he's
saying this does this and this does this
but he preempts it with there's an
argument that there are like genetic bio
weapons basically right yeah and there's
even a news yes yeah in fact it's
Newsweek so maybe we can pull up the
Pentagon making uh race specific bio
weapons to Target citizens China says
according to Newsweek China is making
the claim that the Pentagon is doing
race specific bio weapons uh and this is
his this is as recent as May May 11th of
2023. yeah well and when I saw the so
our FK put up this long thread on
Twitter saying the New York Post is
taking me out of context they are Mis
misrepresenting what I've said here is a
specific link to a study here is what I
meant by this and he ultimately demanded
that they issue an apology because he
feels like do you know if they did did
they the story is still up and I haven't
seen any apologies no correction at all
no correction as far as I could see uh
or at least acknowledge correction and
again some of this is maybe they are
making an editorial decision I'm sure
you can speak to this uh while our
reporter took this quote and
uh well what's interesting too is if you
look at the headline and you look at the
story they don't really match so it
seems like I know John Levine wrote the
story I wonder if John Levine wrote the
headline or if someone else wrote that
headline I know you guys are in a
newsroom right like we have people doing
Graphics we have people doing headlines
we have people writing stories and the
graphic the headline and the story could
all come from completely different
people on the you know the same team and
it's all sort of blurbs you're saying
like oh this is what it's about right I
think it's interesting uh to me my first
instinct when I see these kinds of
conflicts is to say like wow RFK really
has them on the ropes they they do not
like this yeah I mean I mean this is
them really starting to launch into the
Trump treatment of RFK so for a while
they were saying he's a quack he's
spreading misinformation he's a hawkster
he's trying to sell snake oil and fool
people about the Medical Science for his
own personal gain the typical kind of
stuff you hear about anyone who gets
labeled a conspiracy theorist by The
Establishment but now they're actually
moving into this guy's racist territory
right they're openly referring to him is
an anti-semite simply because he said he
wanted to have a discussion about the
degree to which covet seems to have
affected different populations now of
course the left was very comfortable
having the conversation about the
effects covet had on different
populations again in 2020 in 2021 when
they claimed it was disproportionately
affecting the African-American Community
there's anyone who can recognize
anti-Semitism it should be the people on
the Democrat side because they are
really anti-semitic in a lot of cases
pramila J Apollo came out the other day
and was saying that Israel is a racist
State you have ilhan Omar who is
decidedly anti-semitic
um you know it it seems to be in a lot
of cases what the Democrats accuse other
people of doing is the thing that they
are doing themselves all the time well
all the time and there's another element
to this which is really important that I
want to flag they're using this term bio
weapon right they're saying he's a
conspiracy theorist he's saying covid is
a bio weapon and this is a term that
people will generally associate with
conspiracy theory and because it's so
bombastic it sounds frightening but
according to Sir Francis Boyle the
American author of the American
implementing legislation of the
international bio weapons convention
anything created through gain of
function research is a bio weapon this
is the legal definition so if it's
created through gain of function
research which many of these
institutions are now acknowledging given
that they're saying lab leak hypothesis
is more than likely than it is a bio
weapon that's not a controversial claim
that's literally what the law says
that's literally what the man who wrote
the law has said about it and what the
left has done is guess what labeled him
a conspiracy theorist even though he's
literally the person who is responsible
for implementing that legislation in
writing around it and they're saying
he's a lawyer not an epidemiologist how
can he be saying it's a biological
weapon well because whether something's
a biological weapon is not a question of
epidemiology it's a question of Law and
he literally wrote the thing this is
something that's bothering me right now
so I'm looking at the New York Times
article titled Robert F Kennedy Jr heirs
bigoted new coveted conspiracy theory
about Jews and Chinese is that the
article in question I haven't read the
article yet no it's a New York Post
article New York Post okay all these it
looks like these other other outlets are
picking up the the claim it's like a
game of telephone and to be fair you
could see it all over Twitter too
everyone starts coming out saying that
RFK is racist and anti-semitic and
hateful and all of these kinds of things
it really it really was this classic
Snowball Effect where you have
um you know one headline
drove everything a lot of the people who
were talking about this story I wonder
if they even read the article or watched
the interview or just ran with the
headline I'm looking at the guardian now
white house condemned the White House is
now chiming in on it so it's not just
news organizations sister condemned this
statement but this is the thing that's
interesting about rfk's roles and his
own family from the get-go he was the
media's favorite new conspiracy theorist
right the day that he announced that was
one of the first things that came out he
questions vaccines he's a conspiracy
theorist and you know regardless of the
fact that you don't necessarily have to
take medical advice from a politician I
understand that it is interesting that
this was the brand they were going to
use to uh to hurt his campaign from the
beginning and now they're just sort of
going back and trying to find more
evidence of this and that's why I think
it's an important conversation to have
uh was this quote accurately represented
in the article is he referring to a
study is he himself
promoting false information because if
you don't know that it's easy to then to
assume he is in fact practice deranged
person right yeah how quickly we forget
everything we forget the beginning of
covid we forget all of these um
conspiracy theories that as they were
called about the lab leak and everything
else that have proven out do you know
what I mean there's no that have proven
to be true yeah absolutely well there's
another element to this too there's a
couple things I want to mention here
firstly this strikes me
as RFK having his Jewish space lasers
moment so for those who don't know
Marjorie Taylor green is constantly
slandered as having said there are these
Jewish space lasers it's total nonsense
before she was ever elected to office
she made a very long Facebook post where
she was saying things which by the way
I'm not defending I don't agree with but
she was basically saying that she
thought that forest fires were started
by uh or potentially started she
basically floated the question they may
have been started by a satellite which
was funded by organizations that people
claim it is anti-Semitic to criticize
she never it's basically the equivalent
of saying oh if you say something
negative about George Soros you're an
anti-semitic conspiracy theorist
Marjorie Taylor green never ever ever
said the Jewish space lasers thing it's
complete nonsense even left-wing fact
Checkers have said that that's not
exactly true they've given it a mixed
factuality rating which is ridiculous
because it's it is totally false but
when you read their rationality say well
no she never said there were Jewish
space lasers she just said that this
space satellite uh that was funded by
groups that anti-semites don't like
might have started the fire so I guess
my point is this is another example of
the media and the left-wing
establishment seeing somebody is a
threat and wanting to take everything
they're saying totally out of context
and I gotta be honest I've mentioned
that I think RFK has problems there's a
lot I don't agree with him on obviously
I'm a conservative so I'm not going to
agree with him on quite a lot but I felt
similarly about Trump I'm not saying
I'll ever support RFK I could never
support a pro-choice candidate but I
remember when Trump first came out of
the scene I remember thinking I'm not a
huge fan of this guy and then I saw who
his enemies were and what they were
saying about him and how they were
smearing him and I began to warm up to
him so the media is playing a very
dangerous game if their goal is to get
people to hate RFK because the American
people know at this point that if you're
an enemy of a press the Press you're a
friend of the people yeah I think that's
so true well and if you're an enemy of
the Democrats you're probably a friend
of the people too I've got them
like these organizations somebody maybe
somewhere actually saw it out of context
and was like he said these things and
then they printed it and then whether
not they believed they were going to get
him out of context and make stuff maybe
they're making stuff up maliciously
maybe they actually thought it but I
think that then the White House and the
people in the obiden the obiden camp
Obama
let's just let's go with it we he's our
biggest threat he's obviously gonna win
the presidency if he's not slandered and
stopped and he's the biggest threat to
the medical pharmaceutical do you think
he has a chance of winning the
presidency well Michelle Obama
apparently is going to run so no what
about Gavin Newsom he seems to be he'll
probably be Michelle's VP probably I
think so I think if Michelle runs
Newsome won't stand a chance Michelle
Obama have any more qualifications than
Hillary Clinton did I think she has less
I think she actually has less Secretary
of State yeah yeah I think she says I
think part of the fear qualification
right is being first lady completely
it's really personable from knowing
Obama compared to Hillary isn't she
isn't she like anti-fat people though
remember her whole oh get out and move
yeah
I think that's sorry no it's okay I
think it's interesting because you're
right there are lots of cool nice things
people in the world it doesn't mean they
all should be president but with RFK I
think the biggest threat is not
necessarily that he would win as a
Democrat it's that he would run as a
third party and siphon votes away I mean
Allah Ross Perot right like I'd love to
see it I would love to see it I read
some headline that Joe manchin is
exploring a third party campaign I don't
know if that's true at all uh but that
is actually the biggest problem for
Democrats right now because their own
base is not really sure what to make of
them right uh a third-party candidate in
our system is actually dangerous not
because they could win the White House
but because they could take away from
the base of one of these two parties
exactly and so I would actually argue in
many ways the left-wing press is more
afraid of RFK than they are of trump
just in the sense that we know they kind
of wanted to prop Trump up at least some
of them did for their quote unquote Pied
Piper strategy we learned this from the
email leaks we got from the Clinton
campaign uh the truth is that they think
that they can beat Trump I'm not saying
that's true but they believe they can
they have no idea what to do with RFK
they they really are afraid and they're
also afraid of him changing the Status
Quo of the democratic party one of
Trump's accomplishments one of the
things you absolutely cannot take away
from him is he pushed all the neocons
and the warhawks out of the Republican
party or at least the majority of them
exactly a lot of them
more funding for Ukraine yes some of
them are but like he pushed Liz Cheney
out he definitely changed the status quo
he made it clear that there was a
massive base of Republican voters who
were not going to go for that crap the
entire Republican establishment or the
vast majority of Republican politicians
who are popular are uh speaking out
against intervening in Ukraine so a lot
has changed in the Republican party with
respect to the messaging on warfare
because of trump
well I think they're afraid that RFK is
basically going to do something similar
to the Democratic party where he's going
to make it a more hostile environment
for people who support those kinds of
policies is RFK a populist
um I don't know if I'd go that far but I
think there is something to be said for
him being a little bit more in that
direction than anyone else in the
Democratic party is he on the level of
trump I don't know
um but yeah it's an interesting question
how do you define populism isn't a
populist someone who listens to the
people as opposed to trying to do
top-down strategy and a top-down policy
approaches someone who wants to do what
the people want to do well you know
every political leader claims that but I
would argue that populism is probably
more of a strategy than anything else
it's trying to appeal to people it's
pointing to the elite and saying these
people who have pretended to care about
you are actually only out for themselves
or they're incompetent and they're not
actually going to be able to save you
and so you need to select somebody like
me who is a man of the people who will
fight for you basically I can't tell
with Robert F Kennedy if he's a populist
or not because he's he's in with all
those people like maybe not all those
people I don't want to tell ideas with
Biden and Obama but he's a Kennedy so he
was raised in that world he knows all
those people
um I wonder if he'd release finally the
redacted report on the uh
on the Kennedy assassination you know
how Trump didn't release it
Biden Clinton whatever his name is
Biden didn't release it would RFK
release it yeah uh it's an interesting
question
um in in the JFK you know conspiracy
theory is actually probably the most
popular one that we have any polling
data on at one point ninety percent of
the American public believes some kind
of conspiracy was at play in fact uh the
United States House select committee on
assassinations which was formed in the
1970s 1976 I believe ended up saying
that there was some kind of conspiracy
they didn't say it was the CIA or the
Russians or anything like that but it's
interesting because in contrast to the
Warren report which is the government
document that says there was no
conspiracy we actually have another
document produced by the United States
government which says there was some
kind of conspiracy even though they
don't name names even though they don't
say this is who we think did it they do
say there was probably something at play
that people it's so funny to officially
say there was no conspiracy because like
how do you know you can't know
everything there's reviewed ourselves
and we say we did everything yeah don't
ask any more questions well one thing
that I think RFK really did effectively
here is he push back against the main
media and he actually demanded an
apology so that's the kind of energy
that we see yeah I think that was
positive and that's the energy we need
to see from from more candidates so I
appreciate that and I think that more
Democrats who are positioning themselves
Against The Establishment or maybe to
put it this way who the establishment is
positioning itself against need to take
that attitude don't bend the need of
these people obviously I'm on the right
obviously I'm going to vote Republican
but whenever an anti-establishment
candidate Rises up in a party and ends
up pushing them away from the kind of
big government welfare Warfare State
status quo I'm happy about that
interesting I find that I want to hear a
Democrat criticize RFK without
conspiracy theorists in in in their
world like what specifically are you mad
at him about use a policy but that is
what they're mad at that's all they have
though that's what I find so fascinating
they aren't able to use any evidence
they're not able to attack his platform
they just have to go for these like very
uh racially charged you know uh very
emotional appeals to fear that's their
whole yeah that's their whole Playbook
right is they they set somebody up they
say that they're a problem with their
racial views or what have you and that's
what they do and that's how they take
people down you can even see that with
their attacks on Ron DeSantis right you
have Joy Reed coming out and all of
these others saying that Ron DeSantis is
more dangerous than Trump that he's more
racist more LGBT anti or whatever than
Trump all of this kind of stuff so
whoever it is that is a threat to the
establishment power
um is going to be attacked with the
exact act same insults and the exact
same smears and what I think is really
fascinating I keep looking so I grew up
relatively liberal right in
Massachusetts
um Catholic so I was pro-life but used
to be able to be pro-life and liberal
and pro-labor and pro-life and liberal
that was like there is still a
collection of vision pro-life Democrats
they just are like why did you leave us
behind what happened what happened
um but so when you
there were all of these things like
question authority right speak truth to
power all of these very standard things
that Democrats and leftists would say
and now they refuse to realize that they
are the establishment they are the ones
in power these are the views that are
you know taking charge that are shaping
the country and they still act like they
are oppressed you have Joe Biden going
out there like
saying basically that the LGBT community
is oppressed but their flag was at the
White House exactly when the the
American flags you know he goes out and
speaks more about transitioning kids
than he does about what people actually
need in this country absolutely and
speaking of transitioning kids gays
against groomers recently did a sting
operation where they have somebody
pretending to be a 14 year old girl
claiming to be trans call Planned
Parenthood who then referred her to a
community Health Care Network for help
and they proceeded to tell her that they
would give her information on obtaining
certain treatments uh despite her being
underage she said I don't want my
parents to find out about this we will
we'll play some uh do you guys remember
being 14. yeah vaguely yeah you didn't
want your parents to find out about
anything that you thought about anything
please knock yes you better knock or you
might see me oh
we have um we have this this moment here
uh from uh again the the footage that
gays against groomers has posted to
Twitter where
the uh person impersonating a 14 year
old tells the uh people at uh the the
organization that Planned Parenthood
referred her to that she's a minor that
she doesn't want her parents to find out
and this is what they say okay just give
me one moment of finding anything hold
on
can you sure my mom won't find out
yeah now cold Cindy is when um we have
to put labels on your chart so as soon
as I make this chart it's gonna be
contact by phone only and then it's just
gonna be the number you give me I'm
gonna put no mail for your address and
then that's it if anyone ever calls for
you
um we can't disclose any information if
it's not you
know
I mean because I'm under age
you understood but we help underage
patients receive care that they need and
one as long as you know it's not harmful
to oneself we try to help you out the
best we can
okay I'm so nervous my Palms are
sweating
how about you
um right now but the only thing is right
now I'm already at the end of August
looking and I'm not getting any
appointments all right so you guys get
the picture here basically this person's
underage they're saying they don't want
their parents to know about the
treatment that they're seeking out and
this person is saying don't worry we
won't tell them it's a code Cindy now I
want to point something out because I'm
sure a lot of apologists for Planned
Parenthood are going to make the claim
that this wasn't Planned Parenthood
saying that she should do this they were
just referring her which is kind of an
interesting point because Planned
Parenthood is claimed for decades that
they perform mammograms and give women
mammograms when they actually don't have
a single mammogram on site at any of
their clinics they just refer women do
clinics where they can get them but of
course we know they're going to embrace
that double standard and say no we
weren't actually providing any of this
care we were just telling this person
where we could get or where they could
get it that said maybe they bite the
bullet and they say this is affirming
care they absolutely needed it it's
abusive and horrible not to give it to
them I also wonder if this organization
that she was referred to is going to say
oh well when we said we want to give her
medical care uh we're just talking about
like medical care that's necessary for
her life which is a Dodge that they
usually use in order to not acknowledge
that they're giving these children
hormones that stunt their development to
groom them on a path towards mutilation
yeah I mean the the Planned Parenthood
at the beginning of recording refers
this person who's obviously an adult
posing as 14 year old to the Community
Health Care Network the community
healthcare Network when this person asks
like I need help he's like what what do
you want specifically like I just want
help I I I want uh you know you help and
he's the operator specifically brings up
hormone therapy so they are all aware of
what a minor who identifies as
transgender may possibly be seeking out
or they're aware of what specifically to
offer they do mention mental health care
as one of the services they provide they
also mention uh medical intervention in
the form of hormones and I find it
interesting that uh we would have anyone
trying to deny this right like why when
you have this kind of recording wouldn't
you just double down on like well we're
supposed to be doing this like this is
where this kind of logic falls apart
that's what happens right first they say
we're not doing it then they say we are
doing it and it's good a similar thing
happened when Libs of tick tock called I
forget which what the name of the
hospital was but it was a children's
hospital this was last summer it was in
Washington D.C Boston was the first
thing and that whole thing was very
interesting because we did some
post-millennial did some reporting about
what was going on at Boston Children's
Hospital we had the intake form so we
had the forms that said
um uh vaginoplasty would be performed on
young men at the age of 17. we had these
on the actual documentation from Boston
Children's Hospital uh the one for
um young woman to have
um phalloplasties right was at 18.
however you could get it at 18 which
means that there was prep prior to that
probably exactly before you could
consent you could right and so what was
interesting about that was lips of tick
tock posted that Boston Children's
Hospital was doing hysterectomies on
minors and that's what everyone got
slammed for was that she was saying that
we don't have evidence that they weren't
necessarily doing that we only have
their word but they also scrubbed their
site anyway
so after that Libs of tick tock Haya she
called the Washington uh children's
hospital she posed
very very obviously and transparently
actually if I remember correctly
um as a mom seeking to get you know sex
change for her underage child and she
had a similar experience she ended up
reaching essentially the phone answering
person who said yes we do that right who
said like yes we can take care of that
we could do I believe it was a double
mastectomy kind of stuff like that
um and now we have another situation
like that uh
and again this will come out where
they're going to say that this is a good
thing to do because I don't think so
because gender drugs are life-saving and
it's the manipulation of language we had
a mom actually pose this was last like a
year or so ago uh calling the getting
involved with the treasure Trevor
Project posing as a 15 year old with
gender dysphoria and the same thing
happened the mom was as being posing as
this 15 year old girl the mom was
referred to all of these services to get
more gender
medical yeah Services yeah and when she
tried to
at another instance when she tried to
get information on D transitioning the
Trevor Project was decidedly unhelpful
and said things like are you sure that
you want to de-transition this sounds
like internalized transphobia yep that's
exactly right so a person can't be like
groomed into becoming trans there's no
social contagion there even though even
wpath admits there is but when somebody
de-transitions that's because the people
around them have manipulated them
psychologically they've been groomed and
they're not wanting to be trans
basically I think it's interesting with
this call too one of the first things I
noticed that it to me it did not sound
like a 14 year old like there's a
sounded like a South Park character
right it wasn't you ever heard a 14 year
old talk about how their palms are
sweating or she was like I'm underage
like you don't say that when you're no
well my limit was like can you spell
your email and this person goes like
Emma's in Mary like if you're 14 you're
not doing that because you've never had
to deal with that many calls you just
keep saying M waiting for somebody to
understand what you're saying I think
what I noticed about that call is that
the guy on the other end of the line was
like as long as it's not harmful to the
person and there's this I guess the
Divergence of the whole entire Global
conversation on this is is are the
chemicals harmful for 14 year olds or
younger or whatever or are they not and
I think that's part of the problem is
that the information is not clearly
presented like the risks are not
included and this is true for a lot of
prescription medication in the U.S but I
had someone in my personal life recently
tell me oh well Top surgery and
mastectomies are not the same thing and
I have to be like what are you talking
about that's exactly the same what do
you what do you think they're doing and
they're like no no no mastectomy is
different and I was like what do you
think is happening in Top surgery like
there is this what did they say they
couldn't explain it they said you leave
part of the breast no you don't I don't
I mean there's no times it gets botched
and you have weird flaps and things like
I've seen this yeah um there's different
kinds of ways to perform this surgery
there's that gender surgeon in Miami who
does it and eating the yeah she loves to
laugh about the fact that she's
mutilating yeah actually Tick Tock video
about how she was only yeading four
teats during so she was sad about it one
week poses with these minors but um that
doctor has had a number of complications
from patients because of the type the
way that she does it where there's um
what is it no drainage and so people end
up young women have ended up with uh
Rotting Flesh on their bodies and had to
go to hospitals yeah and hospitals are
like uh you're gonna die you have your
flesh is rotting yeah yeah I think
that's the problem like I understand
that there is an argument for you have
to be conscious of someone's emotional
state and we're trying to be
compassionate and open-minded and
whatever else I understand that that's
where uh certain positions on this on
these issues come from but I think
ultimately if you just go back and say
like well what are the consequences of
taking high doses of estrogen of
testosterone of removing tissue that's
naturally occurring your body of uh
disrupting the parts of your body that
regulate your hormones like there is no
way that there are not costs and
consequences and I think we can all
agree in this room that under the age of
18 you are not in a position to make a
fully informed decision I think part of
the problem is that over 18 the
information is still not presented
exactly ethically and clearly well
exactly and that's a very important
Point there's a lot we can say about
these surgical interventions there's a
lot we can say about these hormones but
I really want to flag what you're saying
about someone choosing to do this after
they're over the age of 18 when they
have been told throughout their entire
adolescence that this is something they
should be doing we recognize that
groomers don't always get physical when
the person is underage sometimes what
happens is a groomer meets somebody who
is underage and then they groom them
into placing themselves in that role so
that when they're 18 they can get
together with them if you have a 40 year
old man who knew a girl when she was 14
and 15 and was talking to her and then
as soon as she turned 18 they started
dating we would recognize that that was
grooming even though she was technically
legally of age because we know that if a
groomer gets to someone when they're
young and more vulnerable they can try
to bring clean wash them and so it's a
similar phenomena if you put a child on
these hormones then even if you're
waiting until they're 18 to actually
perform the surgical interventions
you've already warped their mind in the
direction of embracing that intervention
to the point where you couldn't say
they've actually consented even if you
did consent to something like that it
would be wrong because healthy body
parts are not meant to be removed
emulated but even so you can't make the
argument that it's not grooming just
because they waited until the person was
over the age of 18 to intervene
surgically because groomers wait until
the person they're praying upon is over
I disagree with you when it comes really
relationships and things like that I
mean if if if if a if a man is 40 and he
has a relationship with an 18 year old
girl but if he knew her when he was 15
and he's planning seeds like when she
was 15 I'm saying yeah we recognize
universally that that's grooming yeah I
mean I think that we see stuff like that
throughout history
um you know but I don't I don't think
that you can make those kind of
you kind of have to meet people where
they stand right I mean relationships
are weird people have weird
relationships yeah but a grown man
knowing someone when she's underage and
then dating her when she's 19 is totally
sure like I mean my you know in my
family I've seen relationships where the
man is 31 and the woman is 20 and they
get together that's stiff that's
different that's an age Gap but that's
not they knew each other when she was
like a minor and young and vulnerable
and then as soon as she turns 18 they're
together what you're picking up on is if
someone saw a 14 year old and thought on
some level I'm conscious this person is
not of legal consenting age so I'm going
to continue to build what could
ultimately translate into an intimate
relationship and the conversations that
happened beforehand like while there may
not be any physical contact it's not
something that you would necessarily
want it's not something that you would
necessarily want but I don't think we
can illegalize
uh gender transition or sex changes for
people who are of age and I don't think
that we can similarly illegalize or make
illegal is the correct terminology
relationships like that like if somebody
is 18 if somebody is of age somebody is
of age we have to have cut off somewhere
we and I think what you're talking about
too is a separate issue which is the
decline of values the decline of
morality and the decline of a valuing of
childhood innocence for sure
morality and values and what is legally
acceptable and I think we do have to
make that distinction there have been
people who have detransitioned that I've
spoken to who underwent gender
transition sex changes as adults who
fully regret having been castrated they
underwent that surgery in their 20s
there was nothing to stop them legally
from doing that
they are advocating for there to be more
information about this for adults as
well and I think that that's fully valid
and there should be a lot more
information about that because you can't
make it illegal I don't know
I think that's that's the biggest issue
is that we use all of our our scientific
data and I think conservatives can be
guilty of this too uh in a way that
benefits us rather than being like here
are the pros and cons here are the risks
like if you as a kid were around someone
who was very open to you potentially
transitioning when you're 18 I would
hope that you're just as informed of the
lifelong consequences of your decisions
and the surgical or medical intervention
all along like if you are never given a
full picture of what you're about to
commit yourself to then it's very hard
to know whether that's a a decision and
I think that's a huge problem people
don't think it's probably don't get
accurate information and the accurate
information is just not available and I
think in this case it's done on purpose
to then
encourage people to take these make
these choices they're saying that
ultimately these things will make you
happy when we know that that doesn't
bear out and we know that there are
consequences all along yeah well kind of
from a wider view just beyond like um
transitioning and sexual stuff like
grooming in general isn't necessary it's
neutral like you groom someone to become
something and whether you could groom
them to become some healthy adult a
parent Grooms their child to become a
successful parent like that's a form in
the military you're groomed to become a
soldier like these are you're preparing
them to become something so if you're
grooming them for sex of a minor that's
where it is it's not the the word isn't
so you gotta the word that's why I kind
of like calling someone a groomer is
like yeah it's kind of vague like are
you grooming them to be an amazing human
then you've done your job you know what
we're using it for in this context right
nobody says there yeah I mean there's a
difference between like this person is
being groomed for the promotion like you
said 40 year old Grooms a 16 year old
girl and then when she's 18. well they
may he may they may be talking and then
when she's 18 they get married and they
have a happy loving
creep no she's underaged and this guy's
in his 40s and he's talking to her and
they end up getting married that's
clearly grooming she's underage she's
vulnerable she's not in a position where
she can make those kinds of decisions it
is grooming but it doesn't necessarily
it's not illegal and it's not
necessarily immoral
having sex with her when she's under 18
it's immoral I think it's illegal but I
I don't want to be sending her like
naked pictures that's illegal I don't
know so I think it's that thing where
like people have trouble finding out
where the line is especially it comes to
intimate communication with a minor and
I don't know that we would solve it here
in one night uh for me the biggest issue
is like if you don't give like if a 16
year old girl doesn't know like hey if
this is making you comfortable you can
say no even if this person is a family
friend even if you feel like you're
obligated like if there is not awareness
of how to set boundaries and you have
all kinds of problems which is an issue
of the breakdown of families yeah you
know the lack of real parenting I think
that's an issue I got yelled at on
Twitter the other day because I called a
teacher a groomer who was telling a 10
year old to delete an email uh
discussing
um gender identity stuff and the teacher
was like delete this email so your
parents don't say it and I was like this
is what a groomer looks like and
everyone was like that's not a groomer
I'm like no rumors ask you to keep
secrets from your parents exactly
exactly then that's a huge part of it
and I think that's true uh in all of the
circumstances I mentioned and I think
you can ban I think you can have laws
against it and I would
um and I I also I don't like the idea
that you know it's okay for someone to
have this surgery you know the day they
turn 18 but the day before they turn 18
when they're 17 the surgery is awful
it's awful either way you shouldn't be
removing healthy functioning parts of
someone's body yeah I think it's the
purpose of Medicine I just I do think
that
um I do think that
at a certain point we have to let adults
make stupid decisions but an adult
making a decision to Prey Upon a
vulnerable minor is not in a decision we
should allow an adult to make because
involved yeah yeah and so if someone
isn't 18 if someone's a minor and
they're talking to an adult then as soon
as they turn 18 they're together it's
like that's an instance did you see um
remember that show the Jazz Jennings
reality show yeah
I never saw it but I'm familiar so we
had a reporter looking into it last year
and uh she found that Jazz's father was
saying no you can't get a tattoo because
it's too permanent and then in the next
scene they were talking about cutting
Jazz's man dick off geez yeah it's the
whole thing that's cognitive dissonance
is wild I mean this is the same Sorry
God oh of people with that that hate
themselves or that are sad to be what
they are is terrifying I don't know
where or why is it from video games and
people being stuck on the internet and
thinking they're just not in touch with
their body because they're on the
machine I think it's the culture of
social media that tells you you're
supposed to be seeking affirmation all
the time from the outside world right I
think that's a big thing I mean if you
think about what are pronouns if not
saying what you think of me matters more
than what I think of myself or what
reality is there's this constant effort
to get other people to view you in a
certain way to give you justification
and satisfaction and I remember growing
up with the idea that it really didn't
matter what other people thought and so
you know expressing yourself sort of in
a punk rock way or whatever had more to
do with saying I don't care if you think
I am ugly now yeah and now it's very
much like if you and now you press
yourself that we want to and then people
don't celebrate it then because now
you're supposed to say I made myself
look ugly but you have to tell me I'm
beautiful that's weird yeah it feels
like the uh the crowd is grooming the
the social media influencer like the
influencer makes the post and then all
the comments if they're reading those
comments those comments are grooming
them to become what the commenters want
you like
Tumblr you know Tumblr was a huge place
for early gender transitions I've talked
about that yeah that was a huge deal and
I think we still see stuff like that
whether it's on you know platforms that
I certainly I'm not I'm not Savvy in
like Snapchat and Tick Tock uh Discord
whatever the other ones are well feeling
that shame is about to blast us over to
a new story are you no yeah well I mean
it's relevant but basically uh in in uh
light of all these things you guys are
bringing up about the fact that this is
externally imposed the culture tries to
send messages to people we have a former
president Barack Obama
oh no this is uh yeah the first
President Barack Obama
the cognitive assistant is so real it's
the same thing that bothers me when you
say like hey I don't think someone under
the age of 18 should be at a drag show
someone can be like that's life or death
how could you say that but they're okay
with the idea that you wouldn't let an
18 year old heterosexual boy go to a
strip club or a 17 year old you know an
underage boy who's straight go to a
strip club like under some circumstances
we allow these things but not under
others there's not an idea that like
we're all in this to protect children it
seems so strange to me it is strange and
that's like state senator Scott weiner
in California uh pushed through a bill
that decriminalized sex with minors if
they were gay yeah saying that you know
sex with minors if you were heterosexual
whatever that age Gap was was legal and
I'm thinking like why didn't you
illegalize the sex with minors instead
of legalizing yeah
weird it's totally bizarre to me because
you're telling me that you know children
who are lgbtq identifying are more
vulnerable for you know depression for
anxiety for for all kinds of things
studies bear out that most of the time
they are sexually active at a younger
age but yet there's also a lot of abuse
there's tons they're vulnerable in all
sorts of ways but yet when you can take
steps to protect them you're saying
actually no they need to be exposed to
these things like how can you not see
that that is bizarre especially since
you wouldn't treat straight children
that way right yeah right well we've got
the story queued up now apologies but in
an open letter to Librarians former
president Barack Obama spoke out against
the quote profoundly misguided book bans
in school libraries so the former
president uh wrote an open letter to
American Librarians and he appears in a
tick tock video decrying right-wing
censorship push now I've mentioned this
before all of the rhetoric you're
hearing about right-wing censorship in
book bands is basically the left
complaining about the fact that
conservative parents have said that
pornographic material cannot and should
not be shown to children in public
schools and by the way even the the
articles that claim to be sympathetic to
this position that these are book bands
acknowledged that this is a movement
which is being led by parents parents
are the ones saying do not show this
content to my children it is not
right-wing special interest group saying
if you show this book to Children it
will expand their minds and it will it
will reduce our control over the
hegemonic narrative it is literally
parents saying don't show porn to our
children in the books that they are
defending are pornographic and have
pornographic content in them so uh in
the letter Barack Obama called it uh
profoundly misguided he said that books
including controversial books shaped his
life Barack I hope these kinds of books
are not the ones that shaped your life
he said it's no coincidence that these
banned books are often written by or
feature people of color indigenous
people and members of the lgbtq
community interesting is he alleging
that there are books being banned
because there are indigenous or black
people in them it's the most ridiculous
thing I've heard in my life
he's alleging but this this part here is
operative right this is the key the
lgbtq plus Community I agree Brock it is
kind of a weird coincidence that all of
the books that are being banned because
they have pornographic content in them
are being supported by the LGBT
community and your party maybe don't own
that so loudly what do you guys think I
think one thing that's interesting is a
lot of these books and I've spoken to
moms for Liberty about this
um and about the different books and
different moms who are like you know we
don't want genderqueer we don't want
flamer we don't want a lot of these
books a lot of them are actually graphic
novels and I wonder if it would be if
anyone would even notice if they were
not graphic novels because that's where
you see this you see you know uh
lesbians fellating a strap-on and gender
queer
um and that's certainly not something
that you would want in school and I
think a lot of what is being missed is
that it's not that people are asking for
books to be banned they're asking for
age-appropriate material to be made
available to students you know
genderqueer has no business being taught
when I I bought this book myself we have
it here on the table I bought this book
myself to check it out and to say to see
what it was really about and even worse
than some of the images what I thought
was the most shocking was that the main
character
who had been raised in a very weird
situation
um grows up to decide to be non-binary
and the book ends right as she is
deciding to come out to the Middle
School class and I'm thinking that's
even more Insidious why do people feel
the need to why do teachers feel the
need to express their personal sexual
preferences orientations and you know
gender expression to their students I
find that so bizarre yeah you know I
don't remember uh I remember some of my
teachers were married but I don't
remember anything about them no I had
one fourth grade teacher who brought us
all over to her house Mrs Fife and I
remember even thinking at the time like
this is weird why are we at Mrs fife's
house yeah like this is very bizarre I
want to return to the time where like
when you saw your teacher in the grocery
store you were like you exist outside
school yeah exactly
and it's not because they're not human
and have their own lives and can do
whatever it's just because that's the
setting in which children know them like
I want them to feel like there is a a
certain relationship in school and I
don't like the idea that you would blur
the lines for your own emotional
gratification right the other thing too
isn't oh I'm sorry oh I was just gonna
say like the pope had this interesting
comment on uh people having dogs and I'm
going to misquote it I know there are
instead of children yeah yeah he was
saying like the reason one of his base
quotes one of the reasons you like uh
people have dogs is because there's less
emotional work in this relationship uh
than having children and I think there
is something similar that's happening
here where it's like I specifically want
children to be like wow we love you
anyway whoever you are because children
are innocent and when you feel like you
have gotten gratification from them you
know it there's some sort of secure
trapped audience effect there and I
think that should be also these are
teachers who never properly grew up you
know they are that's a huge part of it
are these the role models yeah I mean
when I was a kid which wasn't that long
ago but when I was a kid you didn't even
know your teacher's first name the idea
that your teacher is telling you about
all the perverse sexual things they're
doing behind the scenes is totally
insane but we know why it's happening
happening right this is grooming they
want children to be exposed to their
perverse lifestyle choices because
grooming is essentially a kind of
perverse exposure therapy people
intuitively recoil at perversion and
degeneracy and so if you keep putting it
in front of the child the idea is you
will slowly chip away at their intuitive
sense that this is wrong that's a huge
deal too like when you take a kid to
drag Story Hour right like if you do
that there are kids you can see in
videos of this who recoil and the moms
are like and it's always moms the moms
The Gaslight them they Gaslight them
into thinking it's good totally fine
that's totally fine or the Washington
Post article by a mom who was saying
that she was taking her kid to the pride
parade and wanted the kid to see Kink
and to normalize Kink and or the sex ed
glasses that emphasize pleasure in
second grade and start teaching kids
there's no reason for a sexy class in
second grade period but there's there's
something more to this too which I also
find a little disturbing which is uh I'm
just sort of expressing this for the
first time so if I screw it up you know
you'll refine it later I'll refine it
later but the idea is that
um if you're a kid why do you want all
of this stuff to come from authority
figures you know why do you why are
authority figures getting involved in
what essentially should be a kid's
private emotional life do you know what
I mean like I had this professor in
college uh Danny Kaiser
um and we were studying James Joyce and
Marcel proust in his class and the first
day of class he said I don't know why
you guys want me to teach you Joyce
when I was your age Joyce was mine I
didn't want anyone to teach it to me it
was for me I wanted to learn about it
myself and he said the same thing about
folk music he was way older than us
obviously but I think to a certain
extent like when I wanted to read weird
books when I was in high school which
you know like I was a weird curious kid
I read a lot of weird books I went and
found them for myself I didn't want
anyone to teach me anything I didn't
want anyone to teach me poetry I didn't
really want people to teach me Kafka I
wanted to read those things myself do
you know what I mean and so you have
these people who are not just
infiltrating the educational system and
infiltrating that but they're
infiltrating the private thoughts of
these kids who should be if they're
going to be thinking about these things
that should be their own private
thoughts to a certain extent it
shouldn't be involved with adults with
their parents at the very or they're you
know talk to your parents for sure but
like the infiltration of adults into
children's private lives is really
massive yeah and this is something I
also want to mention that came from one
of the articles I was reading about this
the ala has found that in U.S Public
Schools last year a record 2571 unique
titles were targeted for censorship
often led by parent groups oh no a 38
increase from the eight well eighteen
hundred unique titles Target for
censorship in 2021. now they're saying
that is if that's an indication that our
laws are becoming more Draconian we're
trying to prevent kids from seeing this
literature firstly this is happening
this kind of pornographic content is
being placed into public schools and
public school libraries at a much higher
rate than it was in the past so it makes
sense that you'd be seeing more people
trying to remove them I think parents
are also finally starting to wake up to
this stuff being in the libraries at
their kids schools or being taught in
their classrooms so it makes sense that
they'd stand up and say something but
again the article here acknowledges that
this is led by parent groups who are
saying stop showing this stuff to our
children and also this idea that there's
such a thing as being too selective
about what you're allowing your child to
be exposed to when they're off at a
school where you have no oversight over
them through the course of the day other
than the standards that you've gotten
the school to agree to is Total Insanity
it is a good thing that parents are
becoming more concerned with what their
kids are looking at in schools the fact
that you try to frame that is something
that I see these numbers and I go good
more parents are involved more parents
care about what their kids are reading
in their Ideal World the parents sit
back and say show whatever you want to
my kids I don't care now I happen to
disagree with that which is why I think
the fact that 2500 different titles are
being pulled out of public schools and
they're being told you can't show these
to our children is good because if
parents don't want their kids seeing
that stuff then the kids shouldn't be
looking at it well here's the other
thing though a lot of times it's really
hard to get the curriculum I don't know
if you guys are aware of this no I have
tried to you know at the schools my son
has gone to not the Lutheran School that
he went to for a while that was very
easy but so much of the curriculum is
not on in books they don't send home
textbooks if the kids do worksheets the
worksheets stay at school that's a huge
thing so covid really opened people's
minds to this that's where I started to
really see what was going on at the
school in terms of like weird racial
education and whatever else so that is I
think one of the biggest uh upsides of
the pandemic that's where mobs for
Liberty came in they were like vaccine
mandates no masking no wait and all
these books all of this stuff that you
guys are looking at all of this
curriculum no and there was even a
situation where I think it was in Chico
California it was the Chico School
District anyway it's been on my list I
haven't been able to write about it I've
wanted to for a couple of days anyway a
parent was a mom was denied
the ability to look at the curriculum of
the school was told outright that she
couldn't see it and a lot of school
districts what they do is they say that
the material is copyrighted so they
can't send it home
and they keep the stuff from the parents
before they keep the stuff from the
parents the more angry parents are going
to get I know I was at Mom's for Liberty
The Summit in Philadelphia
couple of weeks ago and when I was
talking to the moms about what was going
on they were really insistent you know
that they wanted to see what was going
on in the schools and they wanted to be
a part of it I will just say though did
you guys see what Barack Obama's
half-brother said about the list yeah no
he deleted the Tweet but he said this
man is definitely gay about Barack yeah
dude Barack shows him a lot you gotta
eat more green vegetables man your
hair's too white I love you brother
Ian's a dietary expert uh ever since I
mean started bulking up for this music
video but I'm not against it I'm not
against it all of your comments just
make me return to the refrain only
groomers ask you to keep things from
your parents exactly exactly it is weird
to me that their position would be well
don't talk we can't show you like there
shouldn't be secrets between parents and
children obviously over time children
develop Independence and things like
that but like the school should be able
to be like no your knowledge it's just
for me and our your kids to look at
right and that is what that is what they
do and not only rumors you really cannot
get this material you can ask you can go
to the school you can say give me the
material you can say can I see the
textbooks can I see what's going on it
is very difficult to get it they say
it's in the Google classroom and then
you try and log into the Google
classroom and the password doesn't work
and they make you go get one just for
adults and then that doesn't have all
the information you can't see it it's
ridiculous yeah well not only totally
different than it was when we were kids
not only do groomers not want kids to or
not only do groomers want kids to keep
things from their parents they also want
to keep certain films from theaters you
guys know where this is going we have
the privilege of speaking to Tim Ballard
last week it was an excellent show I
would recommend everybody check that one
out if you haven't seen it yet but a
former spokesman for a pro pedophile
advocacy group writes in Bloomberg a hit
piece that was targeting the film sound
of Freedom now he made a number of
arguments about how he thought that uh
this is a q Anon dog whistle that
doesn't help victims a lot of the same
rhetoric we've been hearing from the
left he was arguing that it doesn't
thoroughly address the reality of child
trafficking and the way it presents is
misleading he said most of them are 15
to 17 rather than young children okay
the film doesn't purport to be telling
you the story of every single person
who's been trafficked but also they're
all minors every child being trafficked
as a minor frame to play this oh like 15
16 17 so maybe people shouldn't be so
concerned concerned about it while he's
making it sound like it's little kids
well oftentimes it is little kids and
either way it's disgusting because
people are abusing children they're
abusing minors he also mentions that in
41 of cases a family members involved
that's perfectly fine to point out but
again this film is about global child
trafficking Rings it's a different story
it doesn't claim to be representative of
every single instance of abuse that
occurs now part of what's very
interesting about this particular story
is he's a former spokesman for an
organization which tries to deal or
which tries to legitimize uh pedophilia
basically by insisting that pedophiles
be referred to as Maps or minor
attracted persons this is a phrase that
he has argued that people should be
using so I will open it up to all of you
and get Europe yeah there's even a
support group by postasia for people
over the age of 13 to discuss their
pedophiliac Tendencies with adults yes
that doesn't seem creepy at all no not
at all I've got kind of super creepy
this is always kind of gets me how do we
prevent child sex with minor like
pedophilia how do we prevent it very
harsh penalties well you can either just
try and destroy the pedophiles but then
it's like it's like a they can still be
created like a person can still become
one how do you stop them from becoming
one maybe you need to listen to
pedophiles tell their story from prison
or wherever but just so you understand
how they got to where they were how were
they abused why did you feel that way
because if some can identify with them
be like I feel that too so I won't go
down that road Jordan Peterson talked
for I remember hearing a podcast of his
where he was talking about children who
had been abused as you know as kids they
were abused and they had been worried
that they were going to grow up and
become parents and abuse their own kids
and you don't have to right and what he
was saying is you don't have to do that
that he had spoken to more people who
had grown up after having suffered child
abuse themselves grown up and said
there's no way I'm doing that and they
don't do it so it is possible even if
you have been abused as a kid in this
horrific and horrible you know terrible
way you don't have to grow up to live
like that you can overcome it we
overcome all kinds of horrible things
all of the time do you know what I mean
so this organization what it does is it
talks about how this is an innate sort
of thing that you could be born with
this condition this predilection we
overcome all kinds of things that we are
born with right yeah but I also I mean I
totally there's a lot of people who go
along with who become monogamous
regardless of you know we always hear
like oh you know monogamy is not natural
we do it anyway yeah we believe in it
even so we don't have to reject the
framing we have to reject the frame yeah
people are not born this way it's
ridiculous this is something that you
know uh gay rights activist groups were
trying to say for decades in order to
normalize and legitimize homosexual
Behavior but this is what we have to
recognize is that this narrative that
they're born this way is only ever used
to create sympathy for that group of
people so that you're unwilling to speak
out against the actions oh they can't
help themselves oh this is their
attraction oh they're going to do this
no they're not going to do this we don't
have to accept this as an inevitability
anyone who harms a child needs to be
penalized in the harshest possible legal
way and other people who are considering
offending need to see that happen to
them in order to deter them there are
multiple levels to this I was having a
conversation with Sean the actual
Justice Warrior Sean Fitzgerald really
very broke give me a very bright guy one
thing he explains is that there are
basically three tiers to how you get a
person to comply with the law or not
break it and the first and most
important one is that the person
actually internalizes and believes that
that rule is good that is the most
effective way to stop someone from
breaking a rule and you ideally want
everyone to feel that way but then a
step below it if a person doesn't really
feel like there's anything wrong with it
is for them to know that their Community
the people around them are extremely
opposed to it and that if they do it and
people find out they do it or ever find
out they do it they would be low moved
and detested and there would be a great
amount of Shame and then finally you
have imprisonment finally you have legal
penalties this is at the very bottom
this is when those first two fail-saves
break so the most important thing to do
is to help everyone internalize to the
strongest possible degree that this is
totally unacceptable uh and then beneath
that you want to ensure that those
social conventions are held up and
promoted to a degree such that nobody
who is Ever spouting this they're born
that way rhetoric they can't help this
rhetoric any rhetoric that makes them
sympathetic to them is not listened to
and then beneath that if these people do
offend anyway you have to inflict the
maximal harshest possible legal penalty
so we've eliminated shame in our society
yes we have that's second tier yeah
that's second tier we're not supposed to
be ashamed of anything anymore we're
supposed to go out into the street
parade ourselves around naked and kink
filled and whatever else and have
everybody acknowledge that is beautiful
and spectacular it's a very weird
situation where we've gotten rid of
Shame I've been saying
bring back the taboo it's okay to have
taboo I don't think we have entirely
though I think there is an argument that
you should be able to do whatever but I
think there are people who then go out
there and put it on naked and whatever
else and they're like and if you don't
cheer and celebrate me I will think that
you're uh shaming me in some way and
that will hurt me
now now we are shamed for thinking the
wrong thing yeah you know that's where
the shame is it's totally shifted this
is something I want everyone in the
audience everyone here to just pay very
close attention to over the next couple
years because there's something I've
noticed that the left does basically
every time they want to normalize
something and we're seeing that occur
with respect to pedophilia the argument
that's always made is this Behavior
which society widely rejects is
inevitable some minority of people are
going to do it anyway so we have to
ensure that we have a more empathetic
approach to ensure that it's done safely
or only done in small doses or there's
some way to accommodate these people so
that we don't see all of the disastrous
effects that occur now of course that's
not possible you have to stop people
from doing it you can't mitigate the
disastrous effects of something so just
disgusting through some means of
employing an empathetic understanding of
why the person did it right you just
have to put your foot down and say no
we're not accepting this that said that
said what the left always does and what
they have done is once they get people
to say okay it's an inevitability
there's nothing we can do about it what
of course happens is it becomes more
socially accepted and once it's more
socially accepted you get more of it so
the left-wing argument is constantly we
won't get any more of this thing if we
normalize it the people who are already
going to do it will just keep doing it
but they'll do it safely and there will
be less harm that's not true it's never
been true every time they've ever made
that claim we've gotten more of the
thing that they claim to be prevented if
we just gave it an outlet you know what
so they say there's a pressure valve
they say we need a pressure valve to
allow this Behavior do not listen to
that argument don't give them an inch
because if you do we're going to end up
in a country where this stuff is totally
accepted by everyone and you lose your
job for saying it's wrong well we did
that with sex remember kids are gonna
teens are gonna have sex anyway
absolutely so let's just make sure we
give them birth control so that they can
do it safely or kids are just going to
try drugs anyway so let them try it at
home with their parents or kids are just
going to drink anyway so they should
just drink at home with their parents
and all of these things have become
super normalized I think though
regarding a social pressure valve on
pedophilia that it something like that
not that doing it is is what relieves
the pressure but that understanding it
because if someone if you're abused when
you were little and you see now the the
adult that abused you breaking down
sitting maybe in a prison cell or
whatever just losing losing it
uncontrollably sobbing about how they
were abused as a child and explaining it
and being honest about what they've done
okay that might bring you some sense of
relief I don't think so I think it's
going to be more traumatically
totally against uh researching and
talking to pedophiles from prison saying
like how do we get to where we are right
but I don't think that mitigates the
fact that there have to be harsh
punishments right like if your house
caught on fire you may would you would
want to know the cause if it was magical
thing you would not want to know why so
we could prevent it in the future and I
understand that there's a desire to come
to complete compassion but like if you
were abused and your abuser then cries
in jail and says I was abused are you
then obligated to feel empathy for them
when they did something what about
rapists and murderers like yeah everyone
should we normalize those things because
some people are like some people who did
it are sad yeah right and and or
something they should be did that had a
had a tough time
hold on I really have to make here um
which is that because
that I tried to say this before Hannah
Claire uh was speaking but
um I think the emphasis nowadays is put
on us understanding why the criminal did
this the emphasis should be on getting
the criminal to understand why what they
did was disgusting and should never be
tolerated but I'm concerned with the
child that was abused growing up to
become an abuser and how do we how do we
help the child once you become an abuser
our only concern was how do we lock you
away from everybody else and get you to
stop and the thing is we don't know how
we can get people to stop doing it so
what we just have to do is lock them up
away from everyone else so that they're
not capable of doing oh finding some way
to neutralize the threat I know you
agree I do yeah and I don't think it's
impossible to understand what why
they're doing it I don't think that's
impossible but we we need to I don't not
have Shame about listening to it well I
I don't think I think we do understand
why I think we they do it because
they're Twisted perverts who get a
sexual thrill out of harming children we
know why a lot of times they're abused
when they're little and like that's true
but I think you know people will say
that to get empathy for them but if
someone did that to you as a child and
you pass that pain along to someone else
that makes it even worse how could you
do that to somebody because what happens
is I think what happens is it happens to
you so you're like that was so horrible
no no no I'm okay I'm fine whatever
happened to me in my life is okay I'm
okay and then you start to realize like
all the things that happen to you are
okay so then you remember the abuse and
that's part of the okay thing and then
it's like no no I'm okay it's okay it
doesn't have to be that way and there's
a you know I mean I think that I think I
I think a lot of it has to do with the
breakdown of morality as well and this
lack of understanding that uh there are
appropriate ways to live it it should
not be a relative of society and that's
a relativist perspective like this thing
happened to me so I'm going to inflict
this pain on someone else we see that
with hazing right in colleges and and
you see like fraternity hazing and so uh
the freshmen get beat up by the
upperclassmen or whatever I don't know I
never was part of any fraternities
um and then that becomes a normal thing
and people do it it's still illegal
people still die from hazing even in
relationships when one person yells at
the other person then the other person
feels like it's so they're allowed now
to yell back and it's like you've you've
created a cycle and so at some point
you've got to break that exactly like
the way you break the cyclist by locking
all of the people who do that up so they
can't harm anybody else you just break
up with the person and because well I'm
talking about yeah I would actually say
yes yeah if you're in a relationship
with people I think if you're if you're
in a relationship with somebody who
yells at you absolutely think it's
unrecoverable I wonder about that but
yeah it break up I mean there's a
difference
it's very different
emotionally abusive but my point is we
still draw a line at some point and say
if we want this thing to stop we have to
stop it and if we want pedophilia to
stop we have to lock them up they have
to know that they will receive the
harshest possible penalty for their that
will stop the pedophile but it won't
stop pedophilia but I think part of I'm
interested in stopping pedophiles I mean
like one at a time if that pedophile is
still in jail and there's still a
pedophile I guess in that sense you
haven't stopped pedophilia but you've
stopped children from being abused and
that's what's most important like those
kids aren't big you know if a kid just
see that's the ah man I feel like we're
going in circles were you about to say
something oh I was just saying I think
it goes back to Libby's point I think as
a society we need to decide that there
are some absolute hard lines that we
will not cross and for me pedophilia is
obviously one of them uh and there
shouldn't you know as a human being
obviously you want to cultivate a
lifestyle that has compassion but you
can't let your compassion be so overrun
that you are willing to permit other
people to be put In Harm's Way exactly
it is a false Mercy Mercy to the thief
is Injustice to the person that they
robbed Mercy to the pedophile is cruelty
to the child
um that said we've got another
interesting story here uh this one is a
little bit lighter I know we've been
talking about a lot of dark topics
tonight this is a dark topic but it's so
ridiculous that it seems like something
that might have come out of an onion
article which is part of why I wanted to
share it with all of you since this is
Jim cast and you know maybe we should
lean into the comedy a little bit more
but because
it's been a very dark episode we're
talking about important issues and this
is also to be clear an important issue
but a pentagon typo has leaked to
millions of sensitive uh messages being
leaked to African nations so basically
there is a typo that results has
resulted in literal millions of messages
from the defense department from the
Pentagon
being leaked to Molly basically you have
to end your emails.mil so in the same
with it if you email someone at
gmail.com yeah it's really yeah yep so
when you email someone at gmail.com
writeits.com commercial when it comes to
the military it's dot Miguel military if
it's to someone in Mali it's dot ml so a
lot of people at the Pentagon were not
typing the I and so they were sending
secret information and sensitive
information at the very least to this
African nation now now to be clear for
everyone in panics this is still a
serious problem uh but Johanna severe
who manages Molly's domain collected 117
000 emails since January of this year
and many more in years prior and there
they contain a lot of information about
the United States government and this is
a risk which is very real this could
very easily be exploited and what he
basically said is that his 10-year
contract managing that server expires
this week and it's clear that the emails
being sent there aren't slowing down
let's also mention that Molly is an ally
of Russia so not to stoke the uh Russia
Russia Russia Flames at the same time
this is pretty bad this is pretty bad
what do you guys think I think they
should have had it as dot military us
what's up so you cannot mistake you
cannot accidentally type wrong dot
something you have to well maybe a very
explicit word they probably military UK
and the Brits get it who worked at the
uh that worked at the Pentagon were so
horrifyingly inept and stupid maybe the
real problem with the Deep State isn't
that they have too much power maybe it's
that they are stupid and should not have
any jobs at all yeah they have so much
power for the I mean normal amount of
intelligence of a human being
interesting because the the spokesman
who came out to address this was like
look we are actually aware this has been
happening and the thing is we have no
way to fix it because basically they
can't change the dot mil so they just
need to like send out a pentagon-wide
email being like please please please be
very careful because there's no uh he
was saying there's no there's no
technical roadblock here I don't know if
that's actually true I'm not an
information technologist by any means
but uh it is interesting that ultimately
our national security comes down to
bureaucratic error well don't so many
things come down to bureaucratic error
if you look at you know the Biden
Administration and they're sending out
these executive orders to do all kinds
of things get the agencies to do all of
this kind of stuff and it is just
bureaucracy it's bureaucrats trying to
figure out the best way to implement
these things like look at HHS right
they're like oh okay we're gonna
Implement trans policy by forcing
insurance companies to cover all of
these different kind of surgeries the
agriculture department is like we're
going to stop paying for free lunches
for school kids if schools don't allow
boys to use girls bathrooms that's what
we're going to do so it's a it's a
massive amount of ineptitude I just
failure from these people agreed went to
nice State schools and now have jobs
that they don't want to lose and it
turns out that they're idiots and fools
that's the real problem that's the issue
that I see with can so many conspiracy
theories as well it would require like a
lot of these conspiracy theories would
require intelligent people to be
implementing these things and we are run
by fools so yes do we charge them with
treason because ignorance of the law is
not justification for breaking it sure
everyone World Government I just get
them out of office save us a bunch of
money that's a position start over at
the very least I'll say I'm sympathetic
to that position one thing I'll mention
you brought up it's incompetent you see
schools that are having funds withheld
from them for people to for students to
get lunches that was the Department of
Agriculture yeah good old Tom vilsack
who also decided that there that that
grants for Farmers from the federal
government should be based on race first
because we need Farmers based on race
and everyone was like no nobody really
cares about this and I'm like we're
covering the story damn it we are
covering the story well there's this
weird thing where like every couple
decades left Wingers become more
comfortable outwardly saying that we
need to give farming subsidies and Farms
to people uh not based on whether they
know how to farm right whether they're
politics
you guys have tried the whole let's base
who gets to be a farmer and whose
Advantage is a farmer on if we like you
politically and not like whether you can
farm and treating all people who can
Farm well equally instead of having like
racial or political preferences now
um I I also want to mention Too part of
the irony here which is the school
lunches thing is probably the left's
number one issue to grandstand on and
this is why it's always stupid it's
always short-sighted when conservatives
say you know what we need to do we need
to go after the schools that and it
doesn't happen all that often but
whenever it does it gets a tremendous
amount of press from the left smearing
the right because of course it's awful
and it's terrible Optics but they'll say
look these heartless conservatives don't
want kids to get school lunches but then
when Bureau bureaucratic incompetence
results in kids not getting school
lunches we can't lay that at the feet of
the people who are comfortable with
completely incompetent bureaucracies
right it makes me think of like uh
someone's uh who takes hostages being
like can you believe that the police
department wants these hostages to
suffer because they won't give me a
plane like
that's like we always see in the movies
like you know uh if this person dies
it'll be your fault no it's yourself
I also have to say can you just put
yourself in this Dutch entrepreneur's
position who is like hello US Government
I appear to have too many of your emails
I don't think you need to be doing this
apparently this has been going on for
years and nobody stops doing it right
and finally these levels what fools and
videos finally he goes to the media and
it's like this doesn't seem to be
resolving itself but I have these emails
and I don't want them and I don't think
you want to be sending them and I have
to leave you're talking about the
Malaysia guy
manages uh the domain for the government
of Mali and so he is saying like this is
happening and I just I just want to know
like did you call the Pentagon and be
like hello please help me like I I have
this weird first one Pentagon would be
like yeah there would be no way to get
this yeah so well I you know I want to
ask you this because you have more
experience working in Tech I know you're
working for minds.com for a while and
you have a technology background how
difficult would it have been for the
Pentagon over the course of the last 10
years it just kind of implement some
kind of software into the computers that
are being used there to set off a flag
if someone tries to email a dot ml email
address instead for sure yeah yeah I
mean why wasn't how difficult would
something like that have been from a
technological perspective I don't think
that would be I don't know for sure but
I would think that you could internally
block the dot ml uh uh what is that
called X extra code I don't know we
would call that but you could block that
uh maybe they didn't even know the
problem was happening though so they
didn't block it it's I mean it of course
it sounds like he had been saying things
but yeah maybe I mean maybe this is one
those things that the people just never
flagged or considered to be important
enough to run up to the top but it seems
like a pretty massive vulnerability that
there's a country I'm wondering
do you guys want to get off at five and
go home yeah this one Dutch guy is like
what are we doing they're like depending
I was like what's what's molly gonna do
let's go home we're fine we're gonna
we're going home for the evening I'm not
gonna fix this I I think it's also like
there's probably like I want to say
there's like one person who is like Miss
save some email and it's just like not
aware they are the problem and it's
continuously sending it out to the wrong
thing I mean I I find this whole
situation so ridiculous and at the same
time like hysterically funny I agree
with you it's like something out of the
office is it intense like is it like no
I don't want to say God it's a little
too vague but like is there like a force
that's mind controlling these people to
send it to the Russian Ally like the I
think or dexterity I think they're just
or they're rushing it could just be
stupidity but like Ian hold on are you
going don't attribute to stupidity what
you can attribute to Madness system no I
don't think it's intentional I don't
think it's subconscious it should be a
t-shirt that's an Ian shirts
and they're like whether we realize it
or not we're contributing to the demise
of the liberal economic order I don't
know I don't think that's really
happening but it's interesting when huge
mass of people make the same mistake for
a long period of time it's also
interesting how much more invested
people are and being careful when they
have a stake in something so for example
as someone who runs a business as
someone who's responsible for you know
gaining their own income through the
success of the operation that they've
created in our building like I'm pretty
careful when I send an email to a new
domain I want to make sure I got it
exactly right especially if I'm sending
information that I think could be you
know sensitive like a pitch guide or
like an nfla file or something that I
wouldn't want people outside of our
organization to have but these people I
think a lot of them they just don't feel
like they have that much of a stake so
they're not paying as close of attention
to what they're doing and you should
feel like you have a massive mistake
because you're working for the Pentagon
I think that's true with a lot of people
who have jobs yeah exactly I feel like
they have a stake like have you seen
this thing where um what is it gen Z
there's that whole quiet quitting thing
there's the take it easy Monday thing
there's the uh I'm not going to work as
hard as I really could thing there's
like a lot of this going on and it's
like um it's like a it's like
Civilization we have built civilization
up to be so big and powerful and huge
that it's going to take a while for it
to collapse but all of these things are
little pieces of collapse people not
taking a stake people not caring what
happens people thinking that they're
going to continue to get paid and have
jobs even if they stop doing any work
it's one of the reasons I love talking
to people who own a small business like
uh locally there's Black Dog Coffee in
general Junction and I was talking to a
roaster who just like started doing it
for fun and then like when he was
working in construction and he couldn't
do that anymore in 2007 he was like I'll
just go full time and he's built this
business where like the employees that I
met there are like no I just I really
believe in what we're doing and I like
this product and I want it to be good
there is a sense of pride of ownership
and I love that yeah I love that you
have this idea that people are like I am
interested in this I'm intellectually
engaged in it but also like I'm roasting
coffee I I want it to be a good product
I want people to feel satisfied like and
maybe that I I feel bad because I always
a sort of joke with my friends who work
for Corporate America it's like oh
you're just you're corporate gals you
have some jargon and you do some
meetings and like what what are you even
doing and of course there are reasons to
work for large companies I don't want to
be completely uh against it but it is
there is something like I'm saying like
when I was talking to the Black Dog
Coffee Roasters I just really love
hearing how passionate about what they
what they do and I don't know I I wish
more people got to work in environments
like that because when you work for sort
of bigger Souls corporations when you
feel detached from your work it eats
away at who you are you feel
dissatisfied yeah disservice to the
company that you're working for Yep
they're gonna do worse yeah and if they
feel loyalty to you and you don't feel
the loyalty to the company then that's a
problem absolutely well I think a lot of
people not only don't feel any kind of
ownership over the work they're doing
but apparently you don't feel a whole
lot of ownership over the decisions that
they've made this is something we see
frequently with the student debt crisis
the student loan issues and the fact
that Democrats are trying to push to
forgive all student loan debt if they
can not not the Democratic party
officially but many people in the party
want all student loaned up to be
forgiven Joe Biden was pushing for this
obviously the Supreme Court wasn't
having it but we see here uh in some
data that was published by axios here
that Young Americans are likely to blame
the Supreme Court and Republicans for a
lack of debt forgiveness now now here's
a radical idea maybe if you took out
loans the person you should blame for
the fact that you are on debt is not the
Supreme Court and not the Republican
party but yourself that said I'm
sympathetic to some of the arguments
that advocates for student loan debt
forgiveness make just in the sense that
if someone's already paid off more than
they actually owed but because they've
been paying it off for so long and have
such a high interest rate that they're
still in the hole I do think there's
something about that which is upsetting
especially considering these loans are
federally guaranteed so there isn't the
same level of risk for the lenders who
are collecting this massive interest
rate I hear all of that that said it's
hard to be sympathetic when people who
who statistically are making
significantly more than people without
college degrees are demanding that those
people pay their debts off for them and
people who also are earning at the same
level as people who did pay off their
degrees but had to take less money in
the moment in order to pay that off and
they want them to have their wages
redistributed or their salary
redistributed to pay that debt off so
just to give you guys an idea of the
numbers here if you graduate with a
doctorate degree your median earnings
are 97 000 per year your unemployment
rate is about one percent if you have a
master's degree you're median salary is
like 77 000 about 78 000 in your
unemployment rate's about two percent
when you get down to somebody with a
high school diploma your median salary
is thirty eight thousand dollars a year
and you have an unemployment rate of 3.7
percent so people who have doctors
people who have degrees they make
significantly more than people who don't
have these degrees they also are
significantly less likely to be
unemployed so the idea that you could
spend four to six years in an academic
institution even longer than that
depending on the track you were on and
if you emulate debt throughout that time
period and then step out into the
workforce after having all you know many
if not all in some circumstances of your
living expenses taken care of through
that four to six years and then enter
into the workforce not having had a job
before but being able to make more money
than people who had a job through that
four to six year period four to eight
year period depending on your track
whatever however long you took uh is
totally insane and totally selfish in my
opinion
part of it I think is that people expect
that if they study something they're
going to be going to be able to get a
job in that field and that getting a job
in that field should be able to pay off
their student loans and I think that
that's short-sighted as well yeah I mean
if you go to college and you study
gender and then you get a degree and you
know philosophy or whatever like why
would you think that you're immediately
going to be able to get a professorship
and pay off your degree with that the
idea is that you go to school sure you
can study what you want but you have to
then get a job that's going to pay your
bills you know with the future that you
met that you make so I think that that's
the I think that the biggest problem is
the unrealistic expectations of the
students who take out these loans I feel
like the loan system and I am not an
economics person but it seems to me like
it's just completely broken I know there
is an argument uh for like you took out
the loan so you know the consequences it
does seem crazy to me that the federal
government gets to say uh you can't
default on this loan and also we will
ultimately decide if if we'll forgive it
or not like this seems like a broken
system if you could default on student
loans would you issue them right like a
bank would take into account if you're
you're getting a loan for a house they
take into account the kind of money you
make your financial history and then
they make a decision does the federal
government take into account what we
need in terms of jobs so like if you're
a nursing student do you get a better
interest rate if you take out a student
loan like are we giving loans to people
where there is also jobs waiting for
them at the end that system seems like
it makes more sense than we currently
have which is like you're 18 and can
take out massive amounts of debt to
study whatever you think may or may not
based on nothing make money and be able
to pay off this loan there doesn't seem
to be the same system that we have for
every other type of loan out there yeah
no I totally agree with you I think that
if financial institutions weren't having
these loans uh subsidized they would be
more careful about who they were going
to give loans out to I think other
things might be taken into consideration
if the whole system wasn't rigged by
these federally subsidized student loans
you might even have uh financial
institutions considering not only the
major person has and the likelihood of
getting a job and what they might earn
at that job if they they graduate but
also the likelihood of them graduating
what kind of student were they in high
school and ultimately I think the loans
would be significantly less expensive
overall the National Bureau of economic
research published a paper several years
ago where they essentially confirmed
that universities and colleges respond
to the widened access and easily
available money by doing guess what
raising the prices
in most of the raises intuition actually
don't correlate Within increased number
of people in The Faculty they actually
hire more administrators yes I know
there are many people who made the Arts
centers build that exactly so I know
many people who've made the arguments
that there are many colleges that
they're they're basically hedge funds
with a kind of educational front built a
top they take this money they invest it
they end up growing their wealth kids
are paying there to get an education
they don't necessarily improve the
quality of that education as students
move through and the tuition goes up and
they're laughing all the way to the bank
and people end up in this this kind of I
don't want to call it debt slavery
because that seems a bit hyperbolic but
they end up owing significant portions
of their income for the foreseeable
future and again the one reason I am not
sympathetic to the people who push for
student loan uh forgiveness even though
I am sympathetic to people with student
loans is because I don't think that
people who made the decision not to go
to college and who are making less than
you should have to bite the bullet or or
also I mean I'm sure we all know people
who took out you know hundreds of
thousands of dollars in student loans
and we also know people who made the
decision to go to colleges that were
less expensive so that they didn't have
to be burdened with that loan debt or
made other decisions about how they were
going to be educated and I think that's
really valid as well I know one of my
cousins very intelligent wanted to go to
a top school decided to go to a state
school had enough money to pay for that
did that and is now not saddled with
student loan debt has a good job has a
mortgage has a couple of kids doesn't
have to pay for school still I think
part of it is the false promise that you
know college is this door to some great
uh you know ladder to the elite or just
more financial Comfort or stability when
that's not the case anymore I think you
can falsely sell to people if you go to
the most elite University you can go to
even if it puts you in hundreds of
thousands of dollars worth of debt you
are guaranteed success in the future and
that's just not the case even though but
it is more likely I mean statistically
the higher degree level is the higher
education level is I wouldn't say you
want to earn more money yes you may as
the as studies show be have uh more
employment things like that but
if you put yourself in debt you always
have that debt it doesn't go away the
first day you would then have to budget
yourself accordingly you'd have to take
a job that you can pay it off you would
have to choose a lifestyle that
accommodates this debt and if you don't
want to have to do that you make choices
differently and ultimately you're able
to potentially uh generate wealth more
quickly because you don't have to
immediately overcome this obstacle
you've given yourself which is massive
student loan debt yeah well there's kind
of there's a couple different ways of
looking at this but here's one way I
look at it firstly if you got a degree
that was very useful and you're earning
a lot of money and you're the kind of
person who's student loaned up we would
want to pay off because you're massively
contributing you're making enough money
to pay off your student loan debts right
if you're somebody who majored in
something useless and so you're not
making any money well why would we
subsidize useless degrees you think that
if you forgive student loan debt yeah
you think if we forgive people student
loan debt that's not going to have an
effect on the market that's not going to
have an effect on the number of people
taking out student loans that's not
going to have an effect on tuition costs
of course it's going to it's going to
make the problem worse yeah it will just
declare the student loan debt experiment
dead like that's what I want to know
when can we just really overhaul this
system because it seems broken and even
if they forgave some massive amount of
student loan debts and by some crazy
odds which is obviously unrealistic it
didn't hurt the economy somewhere else
like when do we say like okay we've
learned a lesson this system is not
working we're going to do something else
because ultimately that's what bothers
me the most like but it's even a
collective we don't have a collectivist
approach no I think we should a solution
student loans should not have interest
attached to them that's a huge issue I
think I think if it's federally
guaranteed some of the compounded
interest like I can't you end up having
to pay interest on your interest yeah
children don't understand that nobody
but also I still call the most powerful
force in the universe we've caught we've
sold them a false bill of goods too like
pursue your dreams and everything will
work out that's total crap not true it's
just a lie I think your dreams have to
like look there's a couple things like
your dreams have to be good they also
have to line up with what it makes the
most sense for you to be doing in the
world right there's so many layers of
this like some people have genuinely bad
dreams right so some people want to do
things that would actually not be good
for the world uh and and then there are
some people who want to do something
good but maybe they're not the best
person for it right there are a lot of
layers to this I think there are a lot
of people who dream of putting in no
effort that's the other yeah well yes
there's sort of a lack of discipline
like I said if if we had to line up a
bunch of 18 year olds and be like hey
you could major in whatever you want but
I'll tell you that these are the
industries that need
workers they have salaries if you get
through this degree you will have money
at the end like there's going to be a
lag there though as soon as you say like
these are the industries where we need
people to come do work it's going to
take what like 10 years for people to
get up to speed in that area and then
things better than nothing though right
and I think part of it is like why don't
we why do we want a rational decisions
about their future right like why are we
also indulging this culture of like you
could you could do anything but you then
you have to be responsible for the
consequences of that I can't say for
sure you know hey we need nurses there's
obvious delay on the other hand nursing
is a super flexible career if you're at
all interested in the Sciences you could
make any kind of career with that even
if initially you go into one specific
field what are we supposed to do with
all these kids who just want to be
social media influencers and they don't
even want to do real jobs man let's just
do YouTube videos
that's what's coming that's what's after
this well and this is one of the
problems right people will talk about
Ubi one of the of course massive flaws
with it not just as a concept but
particularly in this culture is we don't
live in a society we're doing things
that are necessarily the most useful for
the group are the most highly valued so
you're going to have a bunch of people
trying to pursue Lifestyles and career
choices with their Ubi that actually
don't really help yeah talking about
people that are talking about things
making like weed sculptures Like You
could argue what we're doing when I was
talking about people that are talking
about things that's not contributing
well it's a storytelling so storytelling
is contributing and if you're good at it
it's extremely contributing to society
but like not everybody we don't need
everybody to be a Storyteller you only
need a small percentage of the world to
be fantastic storytelling I mean you
really don't need you know you need
people to do things and then the
storytellers will tell the story of what
you did yeah like the careers that we're
in aren't necessarily as high demand as
like other things out there and this
actually goes back to trades honestly
there are a lot of Trades that need
people to pursue them because we're
running short uh the fact that my
particular skill set doesn't mean that
I'm going to hidemaker doesn't bother me
I just think that if you're 18 and being
given information hey if you don't want
to have debt or if you're going to take
on debt this is a career field you might
want to consider because it will allow
you to more easily pay it off maybe
don't study interpretive dance or take a
couple classes like my degree is in is
in what is my degree in I have a master
it's so funny nice yeah and it's in um
playwriting I was I studied playwriting
all right well that's one of those
Masters you don't usually end up getting
a huge earning potential did not get a
huge earning potential with that uh but
you know perhaps I did or a lot of my
classmates did anyway right and now
they're all on strike in Hollywood well
let me tell you something we've got a
huge earning potential which is why
we're going to go over to Super chats
these transitions have been just
incredible tonight and then you're super
on the other hand we're going to
transition into a new story right we're
going to hop on I feel like Tim Tim on
the farm is is not nervous for this at
least the terms
this has been a fun show and Tim's
having fun on the farm running around
with the other journalists I can't wait
till next basketball yeah the thing is
you'll definitely be back I want you to
know that Timmy liked the farm he may
choose to stay there for a little bit
longer yeah but he's got a farm here
he'll definitely be back what about the
chickens have you ever considered
hanging out with like another guy
wearing a beanie like do you think it'd
be fun to make some new friends you know
what this weekend we are gonna go this
weekend we are gonna go to the skate
park and we are gonna pick you out
another beanie friend that's we're gonna
do just to keep you company while Tim's
gone yeah just keep you company for a
while thank you well Tim's gone that is
so considerate yeah well you know I'm a
nice guy I'm excited for this weekend
that's why uh that's why Tim Put Me In
Charge here while he was gone I feel
like he didn't put you in charge you
just campaigned endlessly and then he
was like did you campaign he pushed him
I said I begged him I begged him I said
I can't do this please Tim and he said
you have to I he said I need this from
you
I'm bigger than I used to exactly that's
right
um we have here Shin cast Lobby on the
the other hand we have super we do have
super chats I'm not your buddy guys as
I've spoken enough leftists don't know
that Kamala didn't slip up when she said
reduce the population these people
genuinely desire it what do you all have
to say about that I thought that was
amazing when she said that we should
reduce the population for climate change
and I'm pretty sure she means it and I
believe that that's true because she is
pro-abortion she is pro sterilizing kids
through sex changes and she's pro-war so
she's anti-life she's Pro destruction
population and she thinks we should do
it for climate change yeah I mean by
definition right if you're this is so
interesting because it depends on how
you frame things when someone says there
are too many people and we need to like
proof uh you know promote methods for
poverty relief in the third world such
as contraceptive methods it's like you
know that's literally calling for like
population you know what's really good
for poverty relief fossil fuels that is
raised people out of five brothers in
the Holy for decades and decades and
normal nuclear families mom and dad at
home together it's also very good uh um
so we have for Michael as a Catholic
animator of half Irish descent I'm 50
sure Sheamus did not take the spoons
which which part of you is sure no he
did wait that's like
watch watch him that's not something I
would do you guys know I wouldn't do
this he's shaking you guys know that's
not me yeah because they were four I
have never in my Hannah Claire seen
anyone in this room use a spoon and I
will stand by see that chair that here
there you go she just defended me you
have a banana player I didn't do
anything with this one please
occasionally Ian uses one in his coffee
to stir it sure but I've never seen him
eat it
that's kind of just drink it out of the
bowl I always travel that's weird
because we have a witness I definitely
have seen spoons in your coffee I want a
big wooden spoon yeah I keep using the
same one I like it it doesn't Dingle and
cling because Luke was getting nuts
about it you got sick of Tim's dingling
and clinging spoons so you hid them
under the house Luke got annoyed with
the spoon sounds interesting
I wouldn't put it past Luke to steal
some spoons I'm just saying Luke
gradkowski my mom has really long wooden
tasting spoons and not any other kind of
normal spoons to cook with yeah so I
ended up stirring spaghetti in these
giant pot with spoons that are like this
long and like that much spoon on the end
we have here from a revolver Taco what
if some Republican decided to filibuster
the sex ed book for kids and see what
happens tell me that wouldn't bring some
attention to it I think that's a
brilliant idea now here's the thing that
would be public obscenity I wouldn't
want kids to end up seeing that but I'm
curious about what the response from the
media would be the response would be the
same as it's been at school boards when
parents show up and start reading these
books out loud to the school board
saying why are you giving this to my
fourth grader and the school board says
that's too you know that's two
pornographic put it back on the Shelf we
can't listen to that here in the school
board and the moms are all like you're
giving this my children isn't that nuts
it's too gross to talk about it and show
so put it back on the kids shelves so
give it back to the children they can
look at it in private like well this is
the thing they always want to hide what
they're doing from you so this is
another example whenever pro-lifers show
like a picture of what happens to none
more child in an abortion the left goes
you can't show people that like wait the
people who do it are heroes but I can't
look at what's being done it's kind of
interesting I was in eighth grade so I
went through confirmation and at my
church they showed the entire
confirmation class a video of an
abortion on a big screen
just some fun festive stuff I mean it's
good
you know I have not been able to be
pro-abortion ever since I mean I really
think there is something to giving the
information like this is it was very
clear it's very clear it's very clear
and I still remember it even though it
was black and white but that's the thing
like why do we if we're gonna make
people make these really difficult
intense decisions why aren't we just
upfront about the consequences I think
it's shame
honestly it's such a lame thing but I
think it's manipulation I think people
don't want you to know kind of what's
Happening probably for war because I was
thinking about why don't they show the
horrors of War because they want to keep
doing it sure and with the way you look
at like War propaganda from from back in
the day and she's like we're gonna go
over there and beat those Germans and
it's gonna be we're not coming back till
it's over over there and then we're
showing you like the gritty realities
what happened young men this is the
thing young men signed up to fight in
the first world war in droves because
they were afraid that the war would end
before they had the opportunity to be
deployed well unless they thought it was
going to be a fun adventure a lot of
people signed up to be in the US Armed
Forces after 9 11. and that didn't look
fun at all I mean we saw people jumping
out of buildings absolutely well the
thing after that but it's interesting
because after that point you're right we
did have uh films that I think of course
couldn't capture the reality of War but
didn't sugarcoat it the way that a lot
of propaganda pieces from the past did
but what they still did is they gave you
know young men and I think Americans in
general a sense of Pride and honor and
what our military had done in the past
so even though you saw the struggle it
was something that you wanted to to be
able to own it was a struggle that you
kind of wanted to be yours and I think
that's why so many young men were
willing to enlist even after seeing like
the horrific reality or at least the
pale image of the horrific reality that
could be captured and I will say I think
as a society we have less exposure to
death probably I mean this isn't true
for everybody but as modern medicine has
advanced you know you go from hearing
stories of like families that have 12
children and only three survive and two
advice we it doesn't have to just be War
but the idea that there are consequences
that there there are sort of death and
destruction around us at one point was
maybe more present and I am grateful
that we have moved past it in a lot of
ways but I do think it is important to
acknowledge that like there are really
difficult things that happen in order
for you to sometimes make the choices
and if you are numb to them then like
that's like Albert Camus talks about
having witnessed executions like public
executions yeah
um
that was something like if you used to
when when there was capital punishment
that would happen in public yeah and now
it's very hidden well it's interesting
too because that's also part of what
makes it a deterrent in a massive way
like doing it in public that makes it so
much yeah you're like you know maybe I'm
not gonna do the thing he did that's
here's an idea uh not that right
um speaking of crime and criminal
behavior of a very important Super Chat
here from uh Noah prunier this is a very
important one that I really have to read
here uh don't mind here just defending
the potato man there's no proof these
spoons were stolen personally I'm glad
Tim what got what was coming to him and
got sent to the farm for these baseless
accusations spoons come and go but Jim
cast this forever so he didn't get sent
to them he chose to go I couldn't no no
he got sent to the farm but it was in
his best interests
Tim Tim was doing a lot of really hard
work and we care about him so we found a
nice farm for him to go to go on the
Tesla Tim we we he's the guy his head
was out the window the whole time he
loved it yesterday yeah she's having fun
he's in a better place you might say
like yeah thank you with wind and sun
and and so the thing I want to say about
the Super Chat there's a couple endless
skateboarding I wanna I wanna forever I
want to point out uh the numerous ways
in which this exonerates me firstly he
refers to me as the potato man which
means he has a racist bias against me
and he's still defending me because the
evidence is extremely strong in my favor
so we have a testimony from someone
who's actually disinclined to agree with
me uh they're saying there's no proof I
stole the spoons that's absolutely true
they're glad they're also happy for Tim
that he was sent to the farm they liked
him their glasses in the pudding
that's a good point yeah there we go
yeah no shimcast is forever lame joke
listen I would have gone for it actually
would have gone for it stupid jokes are
my favorite I would have done the same
thing do you guys think I've got low
energy today or is it more settling no
no no you're in a good spot listen dude
you're working out you're getting amped
one of the side effects is you make a
dad joke every now and again you know
why because you're working on that dead
body baby getting ripped thanks bro
that's right
um we have
Michael Beacon uh to the Bloomberg
writer emphasizing the difference
between hemophilia and pedophilia is
never a good look greed also check out
ink Slayer entertainment on the Discord
showcase and the.com thank you so much
for your uh chat it's kind of funny
because does this person like send the
article up being like I wrote this piece
like hope you guys check it out I worked
really hard on it and it's like we
should defend the pedophiles yeah I
would be very unlikely I think it's very
weird for like a circle to be like wow
good for you interesting yeah I think
defending the pedophiles is always a bad
look always and also a bad for society
really yeah expose the pedophiles and I
mean expose the way they think that will
help people not to become them James or
will it encourage other people I wonder
I'm taking a stab in the dark I don't
know but I but we haven't tried it yet
so maybe I but I mean locking them up
forever seems to work so we should keep
doing that like El Salvador they locked
up how many people did they lock up in
El Salvador like 30 000 people they now
have a very they went from like the
highest murder rate to like as it turns
out like James it turns out jails work
yeah you know putting people in jail
actually works
um we have from James hates everything
dot ml is an easy fix at the server you
can set up uh excuse me
Mallard table to redirect any.ml to mil
or better yet to yet an infosec box to
scream at the sender see this is
somebody who should probably be working
at the Pentagon right no he's too
confident you could have taken any
emails that they accidentally sent to
not Malaysia Molly Molly and then you
could have them redirected to the
military from all those computers like
an auto redirect yeah or you could have
it send back to them and be like what
are you doing stop this is this is Molly
um we have from Captain Titus uh on the
Pentagon issue you can 100 block
addresses to a firewall so all internal
emails can go to that particular
extension okay everyone who watches Tim
cast smarter than everyone
really just I just pulled the quote from
the Pentagon it says uh while it's not
impossible to implement technical
controls preventing the use of personal
email accounts for government business
the department continues to provide
Direction and training to DOD a
Personnel that's going oh
of the
dodcio oversees this matter so they're
saying like we have an issue we can't
totally figure out how to stop it we
think that there could be a technical
solution but uh we're still trying to
train people on what not to do did they
insinuate they're letting people use
their private or personal emails to work
at the Pentagon yeah just like Hillary
Clinton then that's why they weren't
able to change the way that the things
were directing because they're letting
them use like Google yeah like Hillary
so ridiculous but what they're saying is
like we're still working on training
them to add the I to the end of this
that shouldn't be like a big training
you know what because they have plenty
of Dei training they have plenty of like
LGBT orientation training but they can't
can tell them how to do their jobs
correctly they want to end the qia to
that one they're like right we have to
have eyes and everything these people
remember right brilliant we have from
Project Addington says the cartoonist
should be renamed
spooning on
Shaman are you kidding me spooning on a
shamana yeah well they're talking I
think that's uh in that's a derogatory
reference to the the Q Anon Shaman so
Jacob chancelly I just exactly thank you
for using the proper name and I think
that my proper name should be used
because here's the deal this spooning on
label that has been thrown at me by
those in the establishment who are
threatened by the fact that I'm speaking
truth and only know how to dismiss
things by calling them conspiracy
theories is really a worse look for them
than it is for me you can't delegitimize
every single counterfactual that I put
out there against Tim's narrative which
upholds my innocence by calling me spoon
and on forever I have a follow-up
question yeah go ahead uh when is your
movie sound of spoon dumb coming out
we're working we're working on it I want
to point something out though of course
there is no proof that you stole the
spoons Sheamus but there is you I
appreciate that heavy amount you haven't
stopped I think you've said enough I
believe you I think I believe Tim had no
spoons and then you brought them back or
you brought them in I should say from
from elsewhere and that's all that's all
the data we have at this point I'm not
commenting on the particulars of the
situation at this point other than to
say that I am innocent
we have from excuse me I'm going to try
to pronounce this uh a-e-m-t I don't
know if they want me to say like amped
or you know
20 20. you're right where's your
confidence that's a good point
these wonderful people are are giving us
their hard-earned money I want to get
their moniker rice if you want to get
their spoons right dude this is um
oh my gosh uh went to the movies tonight
and saw a sound of Freedom sold out in
their town I don't want to dodge them uh
so we saw Indiana Jones instead it's all
over the place and no one's motives are
clear everyone just wants the dial uh
yeah what if the box office numbers been
for I think they broke a hundred am I is
that right I know they broke 50 million
I'll look it up last week and then one
of my as you're looking it up one of my
my mom just texted me she's like hey
that movie you were telling me about my
friend just came over and told me I
should go see it I was like you should
it's wild uh word of mouthing has been
so interesting to me and it's it's
actual like if you saw the Avengers
movie you're like it's great you should
see it I would probably not go it's
interesting that this movie that people
know is kind of heavy they're still
willing to go see when it's recommended
to them I'm seeing earned over 85
million since it's open on July 4th
office is that is that really recent
that was that was through this weekend I
believe yeah and does that include the
Pay It Forward
I could be incorrect about that it was a
joy to have Tim Ballard on the show I
interviewed him at uh when he premiered
the film in DC he was really an
exceptional human being yeah extremely
just very mild-mannered very humble dude
if I if I was out there doing that I'd
be like yeah that's me I'm the one who
stops the pedals I'm the one doing the
thing that all of you he's like part of
the process she actually asked him about
that same question that the um that the
burlatsky
prostasia guy was talking about like the
difference between you know human like
trafficking and all of that stuff and I
I was asking him about how the left is
trying to say uh that stranger danger is
not a big deal and that all of this
happens at home
um and he was like yeah I mean of course
exploitation can come from anywhere this
is what I was working on you know but
he's of course aware of all that stuff
he's aware of that framing yeah he's I
mean one thing that the uh one thing
they mentioned while they were here was
just what a bold it was to release the
film on the 4th of July because all the
biggest films in the country tend to be
released around that date and they did
and man they're crushing they're
crushing so go see it so go see we're
not going to stop plugging it until it's
not in time anymore I might even see it
again honestly that movie is wild
um so
cam girl as soon I don't like that name
but uh yeah it's a little weird never
never attribute to stupidity that which
can be adequately explained by Michael
malice that's also Fair did Michael
malice have something to do with this
Michael malice you the spins or are we
just any anything speaking of Michael
Mouse I just tweeted at him yesterday
I'm concerned that the pharmaceutical
industry is going to start telling
people to get white pilled
he just wrote the book you know there's
another there's another dad joke and I'm
here for it I'm afraid because they're
gonna be like did you get did you take
your white pill yet are you white pilled
and then they'll show their Pharma Med
and I'm like oh no I love bad jokes
you're like a home in person with these
extra calories and these like workouts
look at me I'm lighting up yeah just
wait so you feel do you feel better
because you've been uh no not yet I feel
kind of bloated because I'm trying to
pack in 2800 calories and I've only got
like 17 100. that's a lot a lot because
I'm a lot of traveling 15 pounds in in
two weeks that doesn't sound healthy no
it's two pounds a week for six weeks
okay
2800 calories
yet no not yet not yet yeah I'm gonna
stretch out my mediums I think so so we
have a t-rock 754 said uh our society
fell when tolerance was embraced as a
core virtue tolerating immorality is not
virtuous why haven't conservatives had
any guts that's a fantastic question
I've talked about this a lot I think
part of it is because conservatives have
their own set of vices that they don't
want anyone to criticize so they'll say
something like oh like homosexuality is
bad or transgenderism is bad but they
like totally reject the Telos of sex
themselves because they won't stand out
and speak up against contraceptives and
so they have their own scale in their
closet and that makes them feel like who
am I to judge who am I to say that
anything is wrong in this Arena because
I'm also doing something sexually
immoral I think that's a huge part of it
I don't think that's the only thing
they've also been shamed one thing the
left has been brilliant and I've
mentioned this earlier
is firstly they try to claim any
negative behavior is totally uh
impossible to avoid some people are
always going to do it we need to give an
outlet for it and the other thing they
do is they turn everything into a race
analog so whenever someone's doing
something that we broadly accept is not
good they try to claim that the people
doing said thing were born with a
proclivity for that thing so that any
criticism of them is actually a
criticism of their immutable
characteristics which they had at Birth
which is essentially something that they
do so that they can find a way to
recapture the Civil Rights era Nostalgia
and play with the framing of these are
just people who were born this way and
you hate them for characteristics they
can't control big part of why I
criticize behavior and not the person
themselves which is why I criticize
pedophilia and not the pedophile I mean
I will criticize a pedophile but I focus
on the behavior because if you go at the
person they're just going to tell you
hey don't don't blame me for who I am
like so I really focus on Behavior well
but I think focusing on the behavior is
why we should say that behavior is awful
we got lock them up rather than like we
have to understand this person like why
they're doing this
say that again so because earlier you
were arguing I really want to focus on
these people and why they're doing this
but but I I think that's that conflicts
with what you've just said
um about
focusing on the behavior not the person
like if you want to redirect someone's
moral structure don't go at them and
they're they're doing go at the behavior
itself put it out there so that they can
look at it with you well I think it's
also important to help people understand
like when you do something it's it's
proper to label you with that thing and
then ideally people like don't want a
horrible label and then they they don't
I'm not saying that's the only Factor
like oh if we tell someone that this
thing is bad they will they won't want
to do it but we're also in a culture
where we say things like just because
somebody did something once like doesn't
mean that's who they are that can be
true depending on how heinous the thing
is like you can if you stole something
once that's wrong I don't think you're a
thief forever right you can repent and
you can repent of anything to be fair
and well that's the that's the Catholic
way exactly and and that said of course
if you've committed a heinous crime you
still have to turn yourself in you still
have to do your time you still have to
stay away from children these people
should still be locked up forever even
if they can be forgiven by God right uh
but but my greater point with this is
when someone does something repeatedly
they're engaged in it's habitual we
still don't feel comfortable saying that
this is something that it's a pro
appropriate for society label this
person as like no I don't know I think
if you're stealing something all I think
if you're stealing things all the time
it's okay to call you a thief like I
think it is okay to let people know that
their actions come to Define them also
there's also a thing too though where
just because you do bad things doesn't
mean you can't point out that other
people do bad things that's also very
true you know I mean you know Jesus does
talk about this what is it this the
plank in your own eye before you the
wood beam yeah in your own eyes or from
not to be others but I do think that we
can say like and the way that you can
say that the way that you can say you're
doing a bad thing is you can say these
are the appropriate values this is the
appropriate way to behave we all make
mistakes still behave this way even
though we're all gonna screw up you know
so it's not about like pointing fingers
but it is about establishing and
maintaining a morality in society and we
used to have that yeah well and we have
completely dispensed with a collective
understanding of writing it's like all
the global moralities have meshed into
this weirdness do you think part of it
is that phrase Live and Let Live I find
is a conservative thing too because like
the idea is you're not going to just go
around criticizing a group everyone's
just going to do their own thing but
yeah yeah I understand the fear of like
forcing your way of life out of someone
because you want to maintain freedom but
I do think that without a collective
understanding of values it's impossible
to maintain we also have people yeah
exactly we would all behave in the
appropriate way we wouldn't cross those
lines you wouldn't go over to your
neighbor's house and take their child
yeah now people call CPS because they
see your kid walking home from school by
themselves someone told me this story
that you're on a podcast of uh someone
who'd been like an R.A in college uh you
know everything's going fine and then
this one girl comes to her and is crying
and she's like I just found out that my
roommate you know it's like into the
second semester my roommate's been using
my toothbrush and it's obviously super
grossed out this way and apparently when
they talk to the girl the other girl is
like my family also there's a toothbrush
like I didn't realize that wasn't
something I was supposed to do which I
think that's crazy
are you sure like this is you hear
stories like this be like it is okay to
force your beliefs on other people a
whole family shouldn't use the same
toothbrush that's my thing and that's
okay I feel like it's okay to be like no
we all collectively everyone gets around
toothbrush we reject this idea I guess
that's very Communists I guess it's
actually capitalist the Communists
wrapped up by the big Dental uh
Corporation that's right I guess there's
like the uh morality is essentially
subjective to the culture of which it's
built but or or Brent but you've got the
The Ten Commandments like there's some
rallies like don't kill people because
if you did that everyone would be gone
you'd lose everybody so you can't and
that's not even a moral thing it's just
like a structurally functional thing I
don't want all of the above you know I
mean it's all the above it's moral it's
functional but um AJ Cook would you want
to say something did you super chat if
you want to say something super chatted
I'll read it all right I think we should
move on to brimcast
take the headphones
we'll see how this goes uh no I was just
gonna say this toothbrush story really
weirds me out I've been thinking about
it for days what a violation to find out
someone that you like are not like you
don't know this girl in your dorm has
been using your toothbrush and I find
this to be like such a good example of
why it's important to have common value
you that understanding of what's up
maybe it's not that's a boundary
situation that's like a weird thing that
can be part I would suspect there are
probably other boundaries that have not
been properly placed in that family
they're all using the same toothbrush
that's just my speculation that I think
maybe these are people who like don't
have a healthy sense in the underwear
thing too like are they sharing
underwear are they sharing Forks
sleepovers with her friend she was just
like two things
do you guys wash laundry with other
people in your house I mean maybe with
your kids you would but like I put all
the laundry in the same all in one pile
yeah because the smells you know it's
like are you gonna take that leap
because once you go in you're like
you're never coming back it's a
commitment level it's like do you mix
your books when you like get married
I want a big uh trust ball I'm sorry no
no it's okay that's right yeah thank you
guys
AJ Cook says Hey Libby this one's for
you Libby oh wow the super General wants
to talk to you he's saying hey Libby you
saw that um Noah berlanski did a
negative review of sof I ran across your
old post-millennial article on him while
doing my write-up for Valiant news I've
been a fan of yours since I first read
it years ago keep on fighting off what's
sof I appreciate it
yeah I wrote that piece this morning
after I saw I read the Bloomberg and I'd
been written I'd been writing on
berlasky a couple of times actually who
is that I did find it shocking I found
it shocking that a an organization
exists to support pedophiles I found
that really surprising that's a boundary
for you you're against yeah I thought
that that was just a little too much you
know I just a collective toothbrush yes
supporting pedophiles and supporting
pedophilia are different
I understand I don't think so I
understand that you know I can
understand how you can see that there is
a difference there uh and you know
basically I am now so uh what is that
probably conditioned by online fact
Checkers that I try and be as precise as
possible but I do think that if you're
supporting pedophiles you're supporting
their actions and you're supporting
pedophilia well because that's what the
left the left absolutely detests the
logic that you love The Sinner and hate
the sin so whenever they start saying oh
we like these people who have this
proclivity given the left wing framework
that always means you affirm their
actions right
exactly that's what I'm saying the left
wing narrative is that it is not
possible to truly love somebody and
disagree with their actions or disagree
with the things they're inclined to do
so when they say oh no no we just want
to help pedophiles
wrong because every single time you say
you like a group what you're saying is
we like their behavior and how dare you
criticize that's the problem it's a
conservative in your family in which
case you're supposed to shun them at
Thanksgiving exactly throw your wine and
their face but that's my point There's
no distinction on the left there's on
the house
he's hanging out he's coming to the left
it's just interesting like the left is
never ever able to distinguish between
people and behavior if you're a
conservative you have conservative views
you're an evil horrible person if you're
somebody who has an inclination towards
homosexual Behavior well that means you
have to engage in homosexual behavior
and if I dislike that homosexual
behavior that means I hate you so
conservatives hate them so when they
start saying oh no no we're not saying
we support pedophilia because we support
pedophiles be us that's that's not how
they view proclivities or what it means
to love or care for someone in any other
context so I don't buy it I think when I
don't buy it if I were to say like I
support murderers I don't that wouldn't
mean that I say that yeah I wouldn't say
a person but if I was trying to truly
support someone that had murdered it
would be to be a emotional support
structure for them to find love so that
they never murder again that's real
support not yeah you go do whatever you
do it's like blind I'm not blindly
encouraging them to do things real true
you know love and bucko's coming in to
uh check on us yeah so it's good to see
our little ad and here but we're going
to take it over to the after show which
will be can I can I pimp the post
millennial first what yeah well yeah
give me a second just I'm am I I'm sorry
are you hosting a show right now sorry
my goodness let's do that one let's do
that if we we're gonna take it to the
after show all right at 10 10 o'clock
around 10 10 uh we're going to be having
the members show you guys will be able
to call in and ask your questions so go
over there and check it out and uh Hey
Libby is there anything you wanted to
shout out there is listen if I don't
shout out the post millennial I hear
about it do you know that I hear it look
I wasn't going to deprive you the
opportunity I got to shout it out on war
room this morning that was fun too hey
time now shouting out the post
Millennials check out
thepostmillennial.com you can subscribe
to the post millennial at
thepostmillennial.com subscribe also
check out human events where I'm working
with Jack besobic and Charlie Kirk a
whole bunch of other great people and
you can find me on Twitter at Libby
Evans wonderful thank you Seamus I
appreciate it of course yeah I know I
was happy to have you on my show I have
loved being on your show thank you I'm
glad you stopped by me too I'm glad you
stopped by uh Hannah Claire hi I'm
Hannah clerimo I'm a writer for
timcast.com you should go to timcast.com
click on the read tab see all the stuff
from us from me our other journalists
follow at timcast news on Twitter and
Instagram it's the best although I'm
also a fan of post millennial uh if you
want to follow me personally you can
find me on Instagram at Hannah clare.b
and on Twitter at HC brimlow uh
excellent night one Sheamus Round of
Applause thank you thank you we're gonna
have shimcast all week Ian you wanna
shout anything out bucko's drinking the
water out of my cup out of my hand I
love him that's so sweet you guys a few
weeks ago we were very afraid for bucko
because there was this we didn't know at
the time we didn't put it together but
there's this giant cloud of like burning
uh uh Benzene and like smoke coming from
Canadian wildfires and God knows maybe
East Palestine but it was he looked like
he was gonna die Buckle was like gasping
for everyone thought this is it he was
the best he's dead and we so we freaked
out we took him to the vet and the next
day he was fine like the the gas cloud
passed and he livened back up so now you
know we took him to the Pharma they're
like hey well we see he's got some
issues let's put him on all these and
we're like I'm I'm struggling with do we
do we use Pharma Pharma wants to want us
to euthanize him he's obviously healthy
he's drinking water hanging out with us
he sleeps while he eats well I I want to
like I truly I believe he can heal he
can rest I mean nothing's perfect and
and obviously we're all gonna die
someday but I want to give this guy the
best quality of life so support me and
support bucko and his longevity I'm
gonna go grab him before he pees bye
everyone all right Serge uh yeah we did
it I guess yeah it's been a long week
but uh I am wow serve.com
yeah it's all good all right all right
thank you all so much for watching I'm
not just going to shout out shimcast I'm
going to shout out Freedom tunes please
go over there subscribe that's my
YouTube channel also if you want to go
to freedomtunes.com and become a member
and support us there you'll get an extra
cartoon each week we're also working on
getting a bunch of behind the scenes
stuff up there so help support
Independent Artists who aren't woke
thank you very much and we will see you
in the members only section in about 10
minutes thank thank you